so why aren't there flying cars you just
jumping right in you don't say hi
you don't say how's the wife already
how's the wife
how's your book it's been on The Times
bestseller list for how many weeks oh
that the astrophysics for people in a
hurry that's been on the on the New York
Times bestseller was for 67 weeks that's
pretty intense
it's great that's that's a lot for any
book much less for a science book and so
that tells me while all these Trump
books are wafting in and out this is Bob
being like a court like a cork on the
ocean waves as the book of the moment
that either praises Trump or criticized
or it criticizes them come in and off of
that list so this tells me that there is
this unserved hunger that people have
there's a curiosity that this is serving
and it's - astrophysics for people in a
hurry that's kind of a that's very
purposefully juxtaposed it's like
neurosurgery in four easy steps you know
if you saw a book with that title you
have to pick up under what's going on
well not to kiss your ass again but I
always say this about you and I think
it's important you make learning stuff
about astrophysics fun and that's what's
missing you know it's not that people
don't like to be educated that they
don't like to learn they just don't want
to be bored
that's a perceptive point because you
know think of the image we have of let's
say you're in a school where most people
don't go to college if you're in high
school and then last day of school comes
what do people do they toss their papers
in the air as they run down the steps
school's out no but what's the rock song
[Music]
forever right so that attitude must mean
the school didn't train you to embrace
curiosity right that learning was a
chore and now the chores are over yeah
so I think the educational system needs
an adjustment forget whether or not you
go to college because you're going to
spend
years not in school than in school even
if you do go to college what you want I
think are lifelong learners lifelong
curiosity yes where once you are trained
and and and and and your curiosity is
stimulated the curiosity we've all had
as children your children don't need to
be taught to be curious they are curious
to the point of destruction of whatever
it is they touch oh what is this egg on
the counter
what is this glass what is this plate
what's under a rock what happens when I
pull a leg off a daddy long you know
they are experimenting with the world we
don't think of it that way but that's
what it is they're all born scientists
and I say this often you spend the first
years of a child's life teaching it to
walk and talk then you spend the rest of
its life telling it to shut up and sit
it's this this is the wrong combination
so speaking as an educator I think a
missing component of school is is that
the teachers is that the curriculum I
don't know but when you get out of
school you should say to yourself damn I
want to learn more it's almost
universally accepted to that that's when
you're learning ends when you get out of
college it's over you say you're done
and if it doesn't you're ossified in
line and that's how when the job market
shifts you're not ready for it because
you don't know how to think you don't
know how to learn right no and it's the
difference in the in the workplace
between the person who gets an
assignment I Joey
Janet I need you to do this that's not
in my job description I'm not trained
for this that's one kind of person in a
workplace another kind of person is but
here's a new task I need you to do wow
I've never seen that before
great let me figure it out right he's a
two completely different species of
human being and what the world needs
more of is like the the second case
where you take a new task and you say
wow I get to learn I'm gonna learn on my
own I'll ask people who know more you
just you just embrace the act of
learning to satisfy your curiosity and I
think this book is capturing that in the
public I must be doing something yeah
yeah 60 how many weeks 67 weeks yeah
yeah that's a lot of weeks yeah every
morning I wake up I'm I'm calm but I'm
really not calm I'm saying holy [ __ ]
sorry you're alive I can't can I say you
can say [ __ ] I could say it Isis we're
human people think you're a robot now
they know this is it's a great sign I
think and I think your podcast is a
great sign as well the success of your
podcast and the success of a lot of
science podcasts that's an excellent you
notice that there's a rise of science
curious podcast out there stuff to blow
your mind is one that I really enjoy
right I really love radio lab they've
always got elaborate interesting science
the annual perennial favorite that so
many people probably the best right yeah
and and yours as well and I love Chuck
nice shout-out to Chuck nice Oh Chuck we
love Chuck he's great but what you're
doing is you're making learning
interesting and that's why it's so fun
it's it's it's it's there's excitement
to it he bring a comedian like Chuck on
with you things get silly but they're
also curious and you're getting these
experts and everyone's talking about
these various subjects and and as you
know not only yourself as an exemplar of
this stand-up comedians are some of the
smartest people in the world they have
it that they have that far so stand-up
comedians are perceptive people yes and
for sure and they're aware and they
notice things that you don't notice they
see the same things you do and get to
shape it in a way you never thought
possible and then you end up laughing at
other things at yourself was it your
idea to do your show with stand-ups so
so what we have there there there was
several of us who have created this
concept and we there's Helen matzos is
one of the partners and there's another
one who's now left but I get his name in
a minute but there were three of us who
David gamble was his name the three of
us got together and applied for a
National Science Foundation grant what
we said was there are programs out there
that serve people who already know they
like science but who serves the people
who don't know they like science or
better yet the people who know they
don't like science
there's nothing for them because they've
already rejected it
they're not gonna tune in to science
Friday because they don't like science
right on NPR right so what we thought
was suppose we bring in a celebrity
we've all that the pop culture draw this
is the pop culture scaffold we bring in
this scaffold and glad the scaffold with
science because whatever the celebrity
does it doesn't matter there's gonna be
science in that person's life
we had the guy who portrayed Gollum in
Lord of the Rings a lot of getting that
suit that he underwear exactly so what
we did was we so we interview him and we
talked about the technology necessary to
portray go him as a lot he portrayed
that live that was not some later
animation he is live and he's got his
whole body wired up for this and he is
that voice and he is portraying it so so
whatever it is that you have done that
you do there is such because it's
evidence that science is everywhere
you're not gonna you can't say I'm done
with science let me sell my textbook and
move on to other things because
practically anything else you do has
been touched by science and so star talk
is a celebration of that and then a jump
species and so now we're on TV now
alright this is a TV show on National
Geographic Channel star talk
and since you started this by the way I
didn't come here to talk about you you
started this where's our fourth year in
a row we're nominated for an Emmy for
Outstanding informational programming
are you gonna keep doing cosmos too
though cuz Oh cosmos so so so I have one
week remaining out of like seven D shoot
days to finish shooting cosmos possible
worlds premiering spring 2019 there's
the third installment of cosmos if you
trace the first one to Carl Sagan back
in 1980 okay you are I used your segment
on wolves on how wolves became dogs Oh
showed it to my kids and that's right
see the little wheel spinning like whoa
yeah that's how dog became a dog that
what you didn't see is I'm sitting at
the campfire
and this in the snowy environment and
they got wolves walking around me there
on these fishing wires because they they
are not dogs right okay they they debate
over the [ __ ] they want
what correct and when they looking at
you it's it's like should I rip his neck
out now or later when I'm more hungry
right they're not there's no eye contact
with them because they you don't that
they don't see you as anything other
than something that could possibly eat
and so you can interact with them the
way you would with ordinary dogs so
they're on these fishing you know high
tension fishing wire that you can't see
against the snow and they're like
hooting and hollering around me as I
described and the name of that show is
and the wolf shall become the shepherd
yeah my friend did a commercial with the
wolf and there's this commercial where
he's running up this mountain and the
wolf is there and at the end of the
commercial they had to get the wolf to
snarl so what the trainer does is he
shows the wolf some meat and then he
pulls the meat away from the wolf and
the wolf snarls and they're like and
then the commercials over he's like no
no there's no working after that like
there's no Yukie not gonna be near the
wolf right like that switch is turned on
done yeah and it's it's crazy like once
that thing snarled everybody just backed
off and the trainer let everybody know
like once I get to this point we're done
like there's no more everybody can [ __ ]
out of here all three of these cosmoses
the original one with Carl Sagan the one
that the privilege of hosting in 2014
and 2019 are co-written by andrian and
she's the the widow of Carl Sagan oh my
and but she it kind of in his shadow
back then but she's hugely creative and
highly enlightened and so most of the
sort of the the the soul energy if you
will the that what makes cosmos distinct
from other from other documentaries
where you're sort of sitting there
learning you put your thinking cap on
your learning cap on in cosmos it's your
feelin cap you're not only learning
you're also feeling the science and its
relationship to you to civilization
to the world to the universe and her
infusion of this she's a highly
scientifically literate writer producer
and so I just give a shout out to her
just working with her as minute delight
his cosmos on Apple TV or so cosmos was
after at first after it premiered on Fox
and then went internationally on Nat Geo
it then went to Netflix so but I think
this run of Netflix is gonna drop until
the next one comes in I think they want
to clear the clear the landing zone for
the next cosmos but it went to Netflix
but is it available for anyone to get
right now oh right now it should be I
haven't checked that's a great question
I have it all on my DVR and I'm scared
to delete it oh I have like 6% left
space but everyone's DVR looks like I
got your cosmos is in there yeah so
thanks thanks for having having them all
in there who's that Morgan Freeman show
but through the through the wormhole
yeah yeah that's that's that's a Joe
Rogan thing yeah you didn't have that
I'd be disappointed huh I say you're an
imposter you're a fake it's it's an
opportunity to be entertained and
learned which i think is what everybody
misses and I think that's that's what's
missing in most public education it's
people are bored and you take these kids
with so much energy and then you make
them sit still and watch something
that's not even remotely stimulating by
a person who doesn't really care to be
there right right and they know they
know this they know this intuitively if
not explicitly that the enthusiasm is
absent yeah they could feel it yeah and
just it's the worst way to learn it's
the the worst way and it's so hard to
skate once you get out of that system it
takes forever for a lot of these people
to just get their excitement about
education back you know what I say when
I address teachers we all by the way
I'll do this right now in this room that
we have this only three of us but let's
let's take a show of hands in your life
with all the teachers you've ever had in
every class you've ever taken how many
had like a singular influence on who and
what you became
give me a number it's gonna be I'm
betting it's five or fewer probably more
like three yeah for teachers what's your
number
well theirs was the one that I talked
about in your show the last time I saw
you thanks for coming on to start my
pleasure it was a science teacher that I
had when I believe I was in seventh
grade
told me that if you really want to hurt
your brain look up and recognize the
fact that that goes on forever that this
is infinite and then just think about
what that means infinite that there
really is no end to it so but how many
teachers such as that we're so
influential on you that one guy saying
that one so he was not one class one he
might be the one and what do you got for
me it's like two and a half and I've had
scores of teachers yeah okay a hundred
teachers at least so what I tell
teachers is be that teacher to your
students we've all had those teachers be
that teacher and in every case it wasn't
because the topic was something you knew
in advance you would like it's because
their energy for sharing their passion
and love for the subject was palpable
yeah and it just spilled out of him and
went into the course through your veins
and your arteries and you walk out of
there thinking wow that was the most
interesting thing I've ever done in my
life you don't even care what you get on
a test after that because you got
touched and you became an enlightened
participant in that exercise in that
exploration yeah it's just so hard for
them to even get kids attentions though
yes unfortunately hatches going on
unfortunate that could be in some places
half the energy of the teachers is
maintaining order I think the success of
your book the success of your show your
podcast and many of these other really
intelligent podcasts are showing though
there's an appetite for this stuff out
there yeah and I'm delighted to be a
servant of that curiosity and this I
brought this just because it's not even
out yet this the you're airing like now
live this is it you're alive you are
okay so this is like a five-second delay
what is this accessory to war oh this
this is like another book I just this is
coming out in three weeks
is this about space war accessory to war
the unspoken alliance between
astrophysics and the military ah yeah so
so this other book was astrophysics for
people in a hurry if you're in a hurry
do not buy people in a hurry this is not
this is not what this is not an impulse
item at the checkout line this is you
got this is this is all about by the way
we know what role the physicist plays in
war the physicist makes the bomb invents
the bomb the chemist perfects napalm the
biologists weaponize --is anthrax and
the astrophysicist
well we sit at the end of a telescope
and wait for photons to cross the
universe and enter our detector and we
go into conferences and argue about them
so there is no obvious connection
between what we do and military strength
hegemony dominance empire building it's
just not obvious that's why this
subtitle is the unspoken Alliance it's
not a secret it's just it's not there
it's there but it's not nobody's talking
about it do you realize I'll just give
an example okay if you needed more
reasons to think that Columbus was a
dick okay let me add one to it when we
were kids on today yeah I know I know
but actually I do have something smiled
Lee redeeming to offer about Columbus if
you have the time I just wanted okay
okay
start off with that you want me start
out with that well how you want to do it
I'll do the dick part okay so on his
third voyage he's in by the time as of
his third voyage he had already planted
enough Spanish flags that Spain had
already begun to set up governments and
infrastructures in these places
he had found ya basically conquered and
so so in one of the places I'd was it's
in the book accurately but they think
it's Hispaniola one of the island today
he has to get back as his third voice
1503 or 1504 he's got to get back to
Spain he doesn't have enough resources
not enough food for his crew so he asked
the natives would you please give us
some of your stock that you have
collected from your farming now this
particular group of natives only makes
exactly the amount of food they need to
tie to the next crop
they don't have surplus so they said no
we don't have surplus sorry Columbus
knew that one week hence coincidentally
there was going to be a total lunar
eclipse with a moon in its orbit around
Earth enters Earth's shadow the full
moon enters Earth's shadow and
disappears and that the geometry of that
event it's just a simple lunar eclipse
but the geometry says that sunlight
passes around Earth through Earth's
atmosphere and takes on sunset colors
that leech into Earth's shadow giving
the moon if you can see it at all a deep
red amber hue almost the color of blood
Columbus set and he knew about this
because he had read the tables the
Eclipse tables all right we'd known
enough about the solar system at the
time too we got that okay actually back
then it was just the known world with
earth in the middle of the known
universe that didn't matter the rhythms
of the universe were known he says to
the natives if you do not give us food
my god which is more powerful than your
God will make the moon disappear and it
will turn blood red that will happen in
one week you have one week to comply
some of them were skeptical what you
can't what others said [ __ ] we got it to
what this guy says look at the ships
they came in their guns their power
their their culture look what they've
got sure enough right on cue
the moon begins to disappear according
to that that is a famous woodcut that
you know you got this Oh some those
viewing the video of this yeah there's a
famous woodcut and notice the natives
bowing to him and he stands proudly cuz
he knows the science he knows the
astronomy he knew this and so he invokes
this to dominate people who are not yet
scientifically literate and within
seconds of this beginning they bring him
all the resources he wants and he gets
and I we don't know what happened you
know back at the island whether the
people survived the winter but he got
back to the island that is one microcosm
of a set of ways that the universe has
been invoked in this I'll give you
another example los alamos one of the
National Labs they today as basically
since their inception are charged with
tracking the nuclear arsenal of the
United States our nuclear power the
nukes that would go into nuclear weapons
they think about this do you realize
they hire astrophysicist I had
colleagues work in there you know why
because there's a room there are two
rooms
I mean I'm simplifying this but
basically there are two rooms adjacent
to one another and a computer between
the two of them the most powerful
computers in the world and there is code
running on those computers that
calculates the energy yields of hydrogen
fusion that's exactly what an
astrophysicist cares about when stars
blow up okay the Sun is undergoing
nuclear fusion right now and that's how
it's making energy and when that when
high mass stars dies they explode as
supernovae this is a natural thing going
on then you over in the universe on the
other side that's a classified room
they are calculating yields of hydrogen
bombs and they have lunch together and
they compare notes the government
doesn't always have the best people but
if you hire some of the best people to
do whatever it is they want and their
calculations happen to relate to a
military project there you have a
two-way street in progress
why do you think the Hubble telescope
that the the mirror issues
notwithstanding which were ultimately
fixed when it was first launched why was
that so successful viewer versions of
the Hubble telescope previously launched
by the military looking down that that
the model for that telescope had already
been conceived and built and was
operating then we said oh we want one of
those okay but we don't that's not
public that this is going on we design
the telescope gets designed it has the
benefit of previous versions of it
having been used successfully but
looking down and we look up this is the
perennial two-way street of astronomy in
the old days and in modern times
astrophysics and the invention of the
telescope you ever said anything yet oh
you just you look you're a good listener
should I keep just keep talking by
preventing you from interrupting okay
fine Galileo perfects the telescope he
learned that it had just been invented
in the Netherlands the the Dutch were
were opticians all right so they
invented the telescope and the
microscope within a couple of years of
one another this transformed science
when did they invent the eyeglass the
reading glass the reading glasses
earlier than that but I don't I don't
know when's that the real advance was
putting two lenses in line with one
another sounds trivial in modern times
but that was a huge leap conceptual leap
and what you would accomplish and in so
doing
depending on how you curve them and how
you grind them grind the the shape of
those lenses you would get a microscope
or a telescope and and we're off to the
races that's basically the birth of
modern science as we now think of it and
and and and conduct it because you say
to yourself my senses I don't trust them
to be the full record of what's going on
in front of me you pull out a microscope
oh my gosh leeuwen Hoch he got the
microscope guy he thought he got a drop
of pond water puts it under his
microscope just to think to do this it's
just water
why do you think that's something
interesting to do he said I wonder he
was curious he puts it under and sees
little what he described as anima cules
happily of swimming anima cute anima
culés
these are like the amoebas in paramecia
and oh oh it is and so he writes he
reports on this to to the you know the
scientific authorities and they don't
believe him they say you know Van
Leeuwen hook we think you might have had
too much gin before you wrote this
letter why would anyone believe this
that there's entire creatures an entire
universe of creatures thriving in a drop
of pond water and so the way science
works is one report does not make it
true you need verification they sent
people to the Netherlands to verify his
results and there was the birth of
microscopy and then they looked at
everything cells you know they need
vocabulary to describe what you're now
seeing well that was the the journey
down small then the journey went up big
and Galileo perfects the telescope he
looks up as whoa I see craters mountains
valleys on the moon the Sun has spots
Venus goes through phases
this became the corpus of evidence for
earth going around the Sun in support of
Copernicus idea that earth went around
the Sun my point is what was the second
thing he did with his telescope he
telephone no he he contacted the Doge of
Venice invited him to the clock tower
and said look at what this instrument
can do for you as we look out into the
lagoon you can identify a ship's
intentions friend or foe by its flag 10
times farther away then you can with the
unaided eye Venice bought a boatload of
these telescopes in the service of their
military defense and this was a source
of money to Galileo and now he could go
look at the universe this has been a
two-way street ever since people have
looked up so this is this is an
accounting of that this is it's and it
goes on and on the first x-ray machines
for airports you're old enough to
remember what
why would they put in because of
hijackings to Cuba basically that they
were armed hijackings of airplanes of
American carriers to Cuba and Congress
that we got to do something about that
oh by the way there's a company in
Boston called American science and
engineering that was building an x-ray
detector small enough to put on a
satellite to observe the universe in
x-rays and because no one had moved use
visible light but not x-ray that's a
branch of the electromagnetic spectrum
we think if their black holes out there
their region surrounding them will give
us x-rays it's a new window on the
universe and then they said oh my gosh
there's a call for x-ray machines at
Airport we've got the technology that
we've perfected to put in a fricken
satellite so the technology for those
ones you walk through the airport
initially came initially yes yes yes
there was a two-way street there was oh
my gosh we need this for security oh my
god we would we were using let's split
let's apply that technology to these
detectors well that's been a lot of the
stuff with the space program right a lot
of the stuff that they devised for use
on the space station and some many other
technologies have trickled their way
down in the break well that's our and
that always happens and even some simple
things because people say why spend
money up there and we should be spending
it down here but there's interesting
fact here that is almost never discussed
the people who still think about the
universe and study the universe are
hugely creative and the creative
energies cannot be pre prescribed you
can't go to a create you might but I
don't know that you'll get their maximum
creativity say I need you to invent a
cure for cancer right now use that
brilliance I'll try but the greatest
discoveries the greatest cures the
greatest of these comes from a
cross-pollination
of interest that people have that where
they were engaged because they were
interest interested just for the sake of
being interested so watch out here's an
example the Space Shuttle it's it's a
glider when it lands okay it's got no
engines it's got flaps there's a little
bit of brakes and the tires but that's
about it when it comes in okay how do
you make sure the thing that stays on
track because they kept drifting in
winds and this sort of thing and so they
said why don't we groove the road so
that the rubber on the road the the the
runway so the rubber can align with the
grooves and stay in a straight line
because rubber doesn't slide well when
you have doesn't slide sideways very
easily on crews when they realize how
effective that was it's now put on off
ramps to freeways if there's a freeway
off-ramp that's a little tight not quite
banked well enough it's gonna be grooved
check it out next time and you could say
well okay that's pretty simple low-tech
solution why didn't we why couldn't we
just discover that on our own without
the twenty billion dollar a year space
agency called NASA but you didn't you
didn't power tools
cordless high torque power tools were
invented to service satellites in orbit
by NASA because you can't just plug it
into 120 volt socket when you're
floating in space so the engineer said
how are we gonna solve this problem
let's make a high torque power tool so
now NASA invents the height now that is
the only way you're buying a power tool
today is that is the cordless variety
all construction sites they're not
looking for a power outlet for these
things so why didn't we invent this
without the twenty billion dollar space
right you didn't you weren't you didn't
think about it you said oh I can plug it
in this is great you're not even
thinking what you need so yes there are
all of these applications but but I
don't that's a good reason to do it but
I don't think it's the best way the best
reasons are my gosh don't you want to
keep dreaming don't you want to keep
looking into the future that would be
ideal
but that's not attractive to people that
are spending tax dollars when it comes
to tax dollars people get super
pragmatic and they go why do we need to
go to Mars now what we need to do is
take care of this and pay for that and
we were the deficit and the budget and
you know so you know NASA's budget today
is four tenths of one percent of the
federal budget so
you take a dollar or a tense one I will
quantify everybody take a dollar bill
and imagine that's your tax dollar and
you can like cut it to whatever percent
you want so let's cut four tenths of one
percent off of the edge that doesn't get
you into the ink you're still in the
border around it all right even notice
that you would even though you could
trim that off the dollar and pay for
anything pay for it so my point is most
of the people who say don't spend it
here spend it there they think NASA has
more budget than it actually does they
just they there if you ask them how much
they think any oh ten percent five
percent you know several percent no it's
one-half of one percent so if you're
gonna tell me that if you can take that
four tenths of one percent and spend it
in these other problems and solve them I
would say yeah go right ahead but is
this is this where you really want to
pull the money from when it's the only
thing that Gaza is thinking about
tomorrow as just thinking about a future
well forgot like you that's super
important but for a guy who lives in
Cleveland who doesn't give a [ __ ] about
science oh excuse me that's like the
person who says okay I don't need the
space program
why don't I need a space for it I have
my cell phone and I have the Weather
Channel and I'd know anything I need
this is yeah you're using GPS satellites
to understand where you are on this
earth you to understand where grandma's
house is when you pull out of it who
created what who created spread spectrum
technology that led the GPS and Wi-Fi
who is that
hedy lamarr old I didn't know that yes
yes she's actress 1941 yes she did
recognize for reminding me super hot
though that was the problem nobody cared
yeah but yeah it took it would take
decades to really realize that GPS is
launched by the military and it's now
hundreds of billions of dollars worth of
the American economy thriving on this
space application but it was a military
intent then it was to navigate the
surface of the earth yeah to navigate
and the first Gulf War was the first big
use of space assets
in the conduct of military operations I
believe in even when hedy lamarr created
it with another scientist the idea
behind it was for encoded
encoded transcriptions or encoded
information during the war well so that
that's a big challenge how do you encode
information that's by the way the future
of this might might come from it's not
it's still not clear the jury's still
out and they're sort of opposing views
on this but you know you've heard about
quantum entangled particles yeah where I
can create a pair of particles that know
about one another and now they separated
in space and in time and if you observe
that other particle it instantly changes
the state of the particle BEC the other
particle that's back where I am and by
the way that they communicate
instantaneously faster than the speed of
light when you say if you observed do
you mean that if you observe it with
anything doesn't matter but you have to
do something you have to do yes so
something has to interact with it's not
Wu into Renault sir but it's so not what
people but you say that people go yeah
if I saw that in a secret yeah so the
problem is the word observed people
thinks is a psychological thing but in
physics it's got nothing it's a
measurement it's a measurement thing
right and so little measuring if there's
a if there's an electron sitting in the
middle of this table and all the lights
are out I can say I think there's an
electron here let me find out and the
moment I turn on the lights the light
interacts a photon interacts with the
electron and kicks it somewhere else so
the more I try to measure its position
the less I know its position so because
you need to the measurement requires an
interaction with it and on in the
quantum scale interactions change the
state of the experiment that you're
conducting we know this we've quantified
it we don't like it but we deal with it
and then the act of dealing with it you
can exploit that fact for other purposes
we exploit quantum craziness to birth
the inductee the information technology
revolution there is no creation storage
or retrieval of information without an
exploitation of the quantum
so and by the way the quantum was
discovered in quantum physics as a
branch of physics was discovered in the
1920s if you were around back then and
your tax buddies who don't like paying
taxes you what would you have said why
are you spending government money on her
on the a demand on molecules if you
can't even see them what good is it all
I can't but would work I just care about
my wood atoms right here I am yeah yeah
shove that where your where your tax
dollar is and so it would look like
you're wasting your own time and
everybody else's money it would take
decades five decades of four or five
decades before we would realize what
role that would play in computing this
creation storage and retrieval of
information and by some measures it's a
third of the world's GDP is traceable to
what quantum physics does for us on a
computing scale so anyone yes
yes well I mean you there ways to do it
there's certain industries that would
still be there without computing but
they're made more efficient with it okay
so UPS tracks all of their trucks with
GPS and with computing devices that
invokes the quantum but UPS predates the
use of this these tools but you can look
at profits relative to their
efficiencies that are enabled by these
technologies as well as entire fields
that didn't exist before computing you
add all that up it's a stunning fact and
so my only point is that you if you want
today to say why study this when we have
these other problems all I do like all I
do is take you back to the cave and
let's say all right we're in a cave and
there's a mountain over there in a
valley and I tell you I tell the truth
at the cave that I tell the tribe
leaders I want to explore that mountain
in that valley no we can't afford to
send you out there now we have to solve
the cave problems first before anyone
leaves the cave we laugh at that that's
an absurd claim to make in caveman days
I don't know if anyone did it but that's
a crazy thought
their solutions to your problems that
might exist and time has demonstrated
likely exist by leaving the cave that
you can then discover so for me exploits
is not just space all the frontiers of
the unknown biology chemistry a I accept
you know those frontiers and then you
can cross pollinate them and transform
civilization and then the last example I
give then I'll shut up cuz I want to
hear you talk to I got I don't get I
want to hear you interact with what I'm
telling here's one you ready okay my
physics professor in college study the
universe love the universe study gas
clouds between stars and studied how
would you detect a gas cloud if it's not
radiating light will they give off radio
waves all right and he figured out what
kind of radio waves they give off and
why and in this he gained expertise in
the nucleus of the atom and he
discovered that the nucleus can resonate
depending on the mass of the nucleus it
will which means depending on what atom
it is on the periodic table it will
resonate slightly differently when
exposed to the same electromagnetic
field he discovered a new phenomenon in
physics called nuclear magnetic
resonance it would then take a clever
medical technologist to say wait a
minute if you can distinguish one heavy
atom from another let me make a machine
out of that put your body in it and I
can then distinguish one kind of tissue
from another and thus was born the
magnetic resonance imager the MRI
arguably the most potent tool in the
arsenal of modern medicine where I can
diagnose a condition in your body
without cutting you open first that is
based on a principle of physics
discovered by a physicist who had no
interest in medicine by the way the real
title should be nuclear magnetic
resonance imaging but that's the other N
word you're not so you don't like that
people don't like nuclear they're less
likely to go inside the machine if the
word nuclear was on it but my my point
is that was
cross-pollination of ideas with clever
people on their frontiers looking over
the fence at discoveries that are being
made it's how we got the microwave oven
that wasn't invented by a thermodynamic
system I CRO waves this is a world war
two attempt to communicate using
microwaves and they found out some guys
chocolate bar melted in the microwave
field and they said what happened there
and they did some more tests and of
course the water molecule and other
molecules common in food respond to
microwaves it vibrates them ferociously
and so you put food in a microwave
cavity the water content of the food
vibrates friction cooks the food there's
still people who today we say Oh nucleus
because I think it's so fast and they
have no fear it's just friction
okay friction it yeah and everybody's
scared that it [ __ ] up the food well
does it no it's just it just heats the
water get scared the whoohoo people do
okay so here's the thing there's certain
foods that don't respond well to the
flipping of the water molecule and one
of them is like bread products it's hard
yeah it gets chewy and leathery yeah and
only if you like over do what you got to
do it just right and you're still good
if you overdo it you can get led that's
kind of it I'm trying to think you
wouldn't grill a steak in a microwave
you would heat up the meat uniformly and
that's that's all it would do cooks
bacon pretty fast yeah but it's a mess
and it splatters all over so you pick
the foods that are best for that
situation as you would pick the food's
best you wouldn't you wouldn't put toast
in an oven at 350 degrees to bread to
make toast
we have toasters for that right so
different things in your kitchen do
things best you wouldn't make ice cream
and your you know and your spin your
toaster oven but people were afraid of
microwaves the one thing they're afraid
of it's not it's not as they're afraid
of microwaves that they're afraid that
of things they don't understand
they're afraid that something's gonna
happen to their food that makes it less
good correct and it's just it's it's
nothing not knowing that people fear my
wife's friend's mom
will not eat something that comes out of
a microwave really she quotes that as
part of what makes her healthy it drinks
a lot of water she refuses to eat
microwave food the whole life is around
not using microwave she won't eat
anything that comes out of her Michael
okay I'm glad that she doesn't you know
she'll she can live a long happy life as
such seems to reheat food old-school
okay one of the hardest thing is
reheating lasagna if you don't have a
microwave Oh true
that's like impostor you can equip it
again you're gonna cook it again yeah
that's a really good point so I think
microwave ovens were invented for
leftover lasagna mmm yeah just a bowl of
pasta just in general yeah
soup yes sweet for soup was good yeah so
you don't have to worry about it it's
not doing anything to it it's not not
sucking any nutrients out or adding any
nuclear radiation correct okay there's
nothing with radiation in the normal
sense other than electromagnetic
radiation it's already light from the
bulb we tend to use radiation in the
context of stuff that would hurt you so
that would be radiation of high enough
energy to hurt you and microwaves are
not in that category I never even
thought about what microwaves do until
this conversation really yeah yeah so
it's a certain frequency of microwaves
that beautifully pairs with the water
molecule and it vibrates it brilliantly
so it doesn't work for completely dried
things
yeah that's why if you put something
that has no water in it it's not really
very useful it happens it's white eve
jerky it's there's still some moisture
in it correct it's why it heats the food
and not the plate
if the plate gets hot it's not because
the microwave oven heated the plate it's
because the foods hit the food and the
food that's why I can usually pick it up
at the handles you can put food on a
paper plate that's right
it doesn't burst a flame doesn't burst
into flame this is crazy
you didn't Joe what is it between MRI
and fMRI oh so an FM I don't claim total
expertise here but I'll tell you the
little I know that MRI they put you in
there in your stationery and then they
make this map of whatever part of the
body they're studying is typically your
head all right but you can do it other
for your joints in other parts of your
body that might require this level of
three-dimensional analysis and it's it's
a 3d map of what's going on in the part
that they surveyed and so you look at it
through slices through that section so
you might see in MRIs of your brain of
your skull and they take slices you as
the slices go through you see like the
eye socket come in and then go out again
or the the nose cavity and and you can
look at it in all three dimensions front
to back side to side up to down so so
depending on the sophistication of the
machine fMRI is they are looking at your
brain while you were thinking so time is
now an active coordinate of what's going
on and they're measuring it as they're
talking to you but correct so they say
oh think the ice cream sundae with a
cherry on top but think of a naked
person who you'd want to have sex with
and the F stands for functional right
and so it's basically a real-time
observation of what's going on Viktor
person there was a woman in India it's
really a highly criticized case but she
was convicted of a crime I believe it
was murder because she had functional
knowledge of the crime scene and the
arguments against it were like if you're
gonna be accused of a crime clearly
you're gonna study the evidence you're
gonna talk to a lawyer you're gonna go
over some things you're gonna be I don't
know if fMRI is that precise yeah it is
that's why you're very disturbing that
this was used in court it's like do you
remember when these Italian
geologists were I think they were tried
because they should have known about an
earthquake before it happened and then
scientists had to say hey guys this is
not how it works like this [ __ ] can just
happen yeah that's so that no I don't
but that's what I do know let me share a
couple of things with you that I've
thought deeply about recently there are
three kinds of truths in the world okay
cuz we're in it like a tree let me give
you three okay the rudy guiliani
okay ready true isn't always true I know
so let me try to okay unpack that okay
you ready okay
alternative facts I did something called
an objective truth an objective truth is
something that is true whether or not
you believe in it and the methods and
tools of science are uniquely conceived
to seek out and establish objective
truths and this I'm in referring to the
invocation of the scientific method
no one scientific result result research
result it's true until it is verified by
other people's research results using a
different experimental method with
different wall current from another
country when your competitor says I
think you're wrong let me show how
you're wrong and they would reproduce
your experiment and get the same result
when you have generally the same results
emerging that is a newly discovered
objective truth about the natural world
and when you have objective truths
they're not later shown to be false hmm
that's an objective truth then you have
personal truths these are truths that
you hold dearly Jesus is your Savior
Muhammad is the final prophet on earth
you you know Abraham is your these are
your personal truths there's a heaven
you're going to no one is going to take
that from you not in a free country
where freedom of expression and speech
and religion is protected mm-hmm that's
a personal truth the problem here is you
can't convince someone else of your
personal truth without some act of
persuasion and in the limit and
act of violence hmm okay in the limit in
the limit this I get holy wars so I have
this personal truth and I require that
you share my personal truth but why is
that's a recipe for disaster and not a
belief because the people who hold a
belief will tell you that it's a truth
so I don't want to take that usage of
the word away from them okay so you're
giving them a beautiful nation I'm
giving them the word truth but modifying
it to say personal truth that's correct
I'm not gonna think they've used it that
way for millennia I'm not gonna hmm okay
they they feel that is true and it's
true in their bones I'm simply saying
that because it's your personal truth
you cannot require that someone else
share it and in this country because in
the United States because God is not
mentioned in the Constitution itself a
controversial thing in its day by the
way actually God is mentioned but it in
a very insignificant way that the
Constitution is a godfrey document and
because it's a godfrey document it
protects your expression of religious
faith because it means the government
has no say in who and what you believe
or why if the Constitution said mention
God and Jesus well there it is there's
Christianity built into the fabric of
the country and if you want to be some
other religion you're gonna have a hard
time because we can set laws against it
this is why so many religiously
persecuted people came to the United
States to escape their country where
they could not practice their religion a
little differently or a lot differently
from what was going on in their home to
in their homeland so that is it a
problem though to call it truth I would
rather not call the truth but I I'm I'm
a big word guy and I respect what
happens to words I don't always like it
but I respect it and so I'm gonna say
there's an objective truth which is true
whether or not you believe it
there's your personal truth which is
true to you third truth is a political
truth political truth is something that
is true because it has been incessantly
repeated
it's and then you just believe it that
what okay what's Hillary Clinton's first
name it's crooked her first name is
actually Hillary okay I thought it was
crooked Hillary this is was incessantly
repeated in the Trump campaign uh-huh
and that that's an absurd example of it
but but but the point is if you keep
saying if you keep saying that the New
York Times is fake news they just keep
saying that eventually people believe it
and it becomes a political truth because
the politicians repeated it so it's a
political truth that people believe it
or it's a political truth because people
believe it which one is it so again
you're you're you try to ret you're
trying to preserve the true fundamental
meaning of the word truth yeah
and I've just given up on that Jordan
Peterson and sam Harris had
infuriatingly frustrating podcast where
they went over the meaning of the word
truth for more than an hour and I like I
said you can do that and philosophers
like arguing and debating meaning of
things for me it's how our people are
using the word that's the meaning okay I
I concede that well we can wait it sings
why I don't call myself an atheist it's
why you can look up the dictionary
definition of atheists and it kind of
applies to me but what is the definition
of atheist in practice it is what
leading atheists do and it's their
conduct and it's their behavior that's
what they say and it's it's it's their
attitude mm-hmm that is what an atheist
is today because they are the most
visible exemplars of that word and most
of their conduct I either don't agree
with or simply don't engage in what
don't you agree with I don't debate
religious people and tell them they're
idiots hmm I don't that doesn't work
whether or not it works that's just not
it's not in me to do that I I don't
purge myself of words that have
religious foundations in them I once in
my facebook I had a friend going up in
orbit to repair the Hubble telescope one
of the astronauts and I said
Godspeed mm-hmm and then I gave the
astronauts name people wrote in in the
thread said I thought you were an
atheist how can you say Godspeed
an atheist got angry with me and I said
okay first of all this phrase is deeply
historical in the space program when
John Glenn was launched the headline was
god speed John Glenn mmm and every
mission where we sent human beings into
space somewhere there is that reference
in the NASA fancy word means I'll tell
you I'll tell you what it means please
do okay so oh by the way I'll get to
that in just one minute any time the
atheists who are arguing that I was
using God's speed as a phrase they all
have used the phrase goodbye haven't
they see you later goodbye where does
that word come from it's from God be
with you it's a contraction of those
three words and why would you say this
you would say this to someone leaving
the city wall where it's dangerous
okay back when you have city-states
you're going to your God be with you to
bring protection for you between one
city one and corrals look out for you so
now what is the source of danger if
you're going to space it's not alien
space muggers it is the fact that you
have space Marauders it's the fact that
you have high speed and high speed is
the source of essentially any death of
anything that's in motion if you were a
part of that disaster so God speed is
like a space equivalent to God be with
you really the origin was just saying
did they say that before there was space
travel did they say God speed I don't
know the actual origin of space travel
of the term I don't know how far back it
goes but I do know it became common
after John Glenn because they're not
gonna say it to Yuri Gagarin because
they were they're all a theists in in
the soviet union i but here in america
in america god speed John Glenn and I
respect that tradition hmm and so I said
that and then they jumped so if a
theists are jumping on me for having
said that clearly I'm not an atheist
and ask me my favorite Broadway musical
of all time what's your favorite Jesus
Christ Superstar and I and I still use
BC and AD in my writings okay
I still do it don't use BCE I don't use
BCE hmm all right well see even you cut
cop attitude right there right yeah hmm
I saw your face you know I'll tell you
why okay okay first of all doesn't make
any sense BCE is not the current era
2,000 years ago I'm going to tell you so
BCE as you know stands for before Common
Era right and c e stands for Common Era
so this is d religious of fiying ad and
BC NB C right okay yet of course they
reference the same calendar right okay
well who invented the calendar we all
currently use in modern society it's
called the Gregorian calendar it was
invented by the Catholic Church by
Jesuit priest in the 1580s assigned by
Pope Gregory to fix the problems in the
calendar because I'm screaming at you
here you can start it's green get crazy
I gotta calm down I'll bring in coffee
the Julian calendar put forth in ancient
Rome had one modification to previous
calendars it had a leap day okay it had
a leap day and okay leap day is how
often every four years this was good
because what are we trying to track
we're trying to earth goes around the
Sun and so we say all right how long
does that take well it takes a year but
it turns out we're not actually tracking
how long it takes earth to go around the
Sun without tracking how long it takes
earth to repeat its seasons and the
repeat the year that corresponds to our
seasons is slightly different from the
year that corresponds to how long it
takes to go around the Sun slightly
different and that difference was not
recognized in the early calendars and
that difference accumulated so that by
the year fifteen eighty four the vernal
equinox the first day of spring did not
occur on March 21st it occurred
March 10th it shifted from the calendar
date that's what happens if you don't
match the cycles of things and the Pope
said we're not having any of this
especially since Easter might land on
Passover and we try to distinguish
ourselves mightily from the Jews so
let's fix this the Jesuit priest got to
study this they looked at the cycles of
the heavens the Sun the Moon the Stars
and they came up with a new calendar the
Gregorian calendar a modification to the
Julian calendar you know what they have
to do to invoke it that to take ten days
out of the calendar to jumpstart to put
the first day of spring back on March
21st
then this happened inoctober 1584 why is
there babies on ten days out of the
calendar so now how much rent do you pay
they have to like invent amortized rent
yeah cuz you're gonna pay for three
weeks instead you know twenty days
instead of 30 did they have to figure
that out
okay point is this was hard-earned and
the whole world uses this calendar it is
the most accurate calendar ever devised
you know yes I'll tell you what okay you
asked so watch what happens the leap day
overcorrected the calendar it over
corrected it over correct yes yes so you
need a leap here so no so the leap day
is every four years that one day every
four years was slowly putting too many
days into the moments into the year okay
the Gregorian calendar figured this out
and it had put ten extra days since the
Julian calendar to the Gregorian
calendar ten extra days first jumpstart
get rid of the ten days now everything's
lined up again okay now how do you
prevent this from happening again
because it over corrects how long do you
have to wait to remove a leap day that
you would otherwise put in okay okay
that's every hundred years
oh so every hundred years that would be
a leap day you remove the leap day now
turns out that under corrects it by an
even smaller amount okay so how long do
you have to wait before you have to put
a leap day back in ever
400 years Oh God so the year 2000 was a
century year which normally would not
have a leap day except it's a century
year evenly divisible by 400 so they put
the leap day back in and everybody on
February almost everybody everybody
except the astronomers on February 29th
in the year 2000 set it's just a leap
year because it's divisible by 4 no it
is a rarely Pierre
it is a century year divisible by 400
that corrects it back and so now you
have a stable calendar for tens of
thousands of years I gotta give props to
the Jesuit priest I'm not gonna say no
I'm taking the Christianity out of this
reference because they figured out the
calendar that we all use and it's a
[ __ ] awesome count sorry to drop an
f-bomb so I'm not just because some
atheists are telling me that Rid God out
of everything in the universe that I'm
not I'm not doing that
I'm going to say they came up with this
calendar the reasons were because they
didn't want to confuse it with Passover
the motivation is whatever it is but the
sciences is good and so there it is so
in accessori to war where we go back
many centuries the editors said well we
should use BCE cuz as a liberal forward
thing I said I am not using BCE and see
yep and by the way then there was no
year 0 you know why there's no year 0
because the Romans came up with the
calendar and they counted using Roman
numerals and Roman numerals don't have a
zero oh it was not yet invented no no so
it went from 1 BC to AD 1 VC's before
Christ
ad is anno domini in Latin the year of
our Lord Wow yeah now of course in Islam
and in China and in in Hebrew cultures
Israel in particular they have access to
the Chinese calendar the Muslim calendar
Muslim of course dates to Muhammad
Chinese calendar dates to actually a
planetary alignment in 4,700 BC if they
don't they use a different system I use
a different system that's why
and the Hebrew calendar dates to like
the beginning of the universe as
interpreted in the in the Torah so they
have access to those but when the
conducting international business would
just simply use the Gregorian calendar
just get over it but use it in China do
they use it constantly and consistently
or do they alternate between the
Gregorian calendar and something else
I'm not a Chinese expert but from what I
know of China and my friends and
colleagues they have for conducting
business the world's business is
conducted in on the Gregorian calendar
with the 12-month calendar with with the
year as referenced by everybody else and
does it have to be done that way in
terms of like is there is anyone ever
done a study on possibly creating a more
effective more accurate calendar it
doesn't invoke leap years and the
problem is the length of the day does
not cut evenly to the time it takes
earth to go around the Sun so there will
always be fractions of days that you're
accumulating right and now what do you
do with them you wait till you
accumulate a day and you put it in or
take it out what did the Mayan this is
enough isn't a lunar cycle calendar it
was that accounted abased on Venus and
so yeah that a really good calendar yeah
it was overstated than it was like the
really accurate count overstated
overstate it was good better than
anything that came before and not as
good as the ignorant no no Gregorian
Kevin
people love old [ __ ] though they do and
they want to believe that especially
people who you know you want to believe
the people 5,000 years ago somehow knew
more about the universe than we do yeah
just know why is that why they wanted to
believe that I think I don't know for me
that's one of the great puzzles of life
why do people want to believe that the
Egyptians somehow had some access to the
universe well they knew something Martin
they of course they definitely knew how
to find some incredible [ __ ] course
right but that yep oh I don't take that
away from doesn't the physical just the
presence of these incredible buildings
leave the possibility that maybe they
had some knowledge that we lost lost
knowledge is a real thing yeah I don't
want to belittle or diminish the
significance of real knows we forgot how
to draw in perspective you know
from ancient times had to be
rediscovered in the as I understand from
the artists had to be rediscovered in
the Renaissance the archway the the
Roman arch had to sort of be
rediscovered okay so yes yes you can
lose knowledge but if you look at the
knowledge we have gleaned using the
methods and modern methods and tools of
science that go far beyond our five
senses in our access to the world to say
that somehow they knew something that we
don't using our tools that's just false
sorry that's just it's just that it's
not possible but we know the
physiological limits of your ability to
know what's going on around you right
and there people say oh I have a sixth
sense fine but as a scientist I have
dozens of senses right okay I can
measure things that your five senses
can't I can measure the magnetic field
around you their electromagnetic field
how much microwaves are coursing through
your body now we have no sensors for
this I can see auras fine I can see
other things that are affecting your
body now I can tell you if ionizing
radiation is passing through you I have
Geiger counters that can do that you
can't
oh you'll finally you'll eventually
learn whether you're exposed to ionizing
radiation because you're you'll get
cancer of your organs and your limbs
fall off all right I concede that we
know far more today yes perhaps
no not even perhaps then at any other
time yes inconceivable history yes but
it is possible that they knew some
things like how to build a pyramid yes
that we really just don't understand
today I don't know what it means to not
understand how to build a pyramid today
we have we have we have 150 story
building so we're not thinking about
pyramid stuff I can tell you this do you
know whether the first thing that was
built by humans ever no no the that's
only part of the sins sorry I love your
enthusiasm my sense only barely came out
of my mouth
the tallest thing humans built after the
pyramids I think it's a building in
Dubai No
so in other words what's the next tell
this thing after the pyramids oh right
after yeah what is the next tallest
thing we built stable structure after
the pyramids what the Eiffel Tower
well yes 18 whatever at eighty nine
eighteen said late 1800s in Paris the
Eiffel Tower huh that was the first
stable structure we built as a
civilization that was taller than the
pyramids so the Egyptians new pad and a
new architecture they knew no one's
taking that away from them but to claim
they have some secret knowledge of the
functionings of the universe no no well
people love seeing that kind of stuff
yeah it makes for a great TV but the
fact that they didn't have steel and the
fact that you're dealing with the very
very most recent 2500 BC and they built
you just have to be more ingenious more
interview yes and we otherwise would
have to be yeah how do you move the
blocks howdy how they make Stonehenge
those those rocks are nowhere in the
region mm-hmm they were carted from
somewhat they found a place where those
rocks were would have been mined removed
and yeah those are some big-ass rocks
yeah as are the one but it's not less
impressive because they're just big like
what the the thing about the pyramids is
so impressive is the precision and the
sheer numbers two million our best
hunters hundred thousand stones our best
understanding of Stonehenge is that it's
a functioning observatory that can
actually predict eclipses so did I get
just good yeah bitch-slap you there
[Laughter]
solstice they have there are holes that
are not stones but they're 56 holes
which is three times the the serous
which is the cycle of eclipses of the
matching of the orbits of the Sun and
the moon in the sky of the paths of the
Sun and the moon in the sky and when
they match up you get in Eclipse is
there is this an observatory guy named
that's absolutely what it is there's a
book published in this in the 1970s by a
guy named
David Dawkins it's not Richard Dawkins
but it's another one of these Hawking's
a rich Richard Hawkins Richard Hawkins
Hawking Hawking Hawking's damn when I'm
dudes damn what well we got our top
crack researchers here just look up that
the Taliban's book with stonehenge
decoded just look up the title a book
anyhow it's highly convincing and we all
were all there with it there's no it's
essentially just a study of the position
of the stones in relationship to the
where the okay Carol Gerald Hawkins
thank you yeah Stonehenge decoded so he
visited Stonehenge as a kid at age
fifteen on an expedition and he was the
expedition head oh wow yeah so how lucky
for you yeah it was it was good and that
stuck with me which is why I named this
phenomenon in Manhattan where the Sun
sets along the stress yeah yeah so so I
named it Manhattanhenge sort of
harkening back to my early days thinking
about the alignment of the Sun and
structures that we might build so twice
a year for those viewers or listeners
who don't know twice a year the
Manhattan Street grid which is not
perfectly aligned north-south the
Manhattan Street grid will that the Sun
will set exactly on the grid and I'll
agree and what's up there now that image
what's not obvious is that picture is
taken along a street that is itself
three miles long and then you're
crossing a the Hudson River and then
there's New Jersey on the other side so
people try to zoom in on it but really
what you really should do is zoom out
from it and then you get the vanishing
point on it so yeah all those are zoom
zoomed in let's go to yeah that one
looks more like like my photo I go back
to that other one yeah see so so that's
on 34th Street the one you see now and
then you get this sparkling effect that
happens twice a year twice like that
sort of crazy wild light effect yes it
looks yes Photoshop dolls yeah
there's an image on his Instagram that
is linked on my Instagram the most
recent photo okay
there he goes oh there's you with the
selfie selfie right oh yeah so come on
down for a fro oh yeah that's strong
that was my first cell phone yeah I was
fourteen four let me see it was nineteen
probably 1974 Wow so I would have been
15 I think I've been 14 or 15 so your
path of curiosity was set back that goes
back very early right but that's nothing
what we're looking for here let's go but
that one thinking it is so that no
there's another one but go back to all
of these rivers Wow zoom back out it's
you see all the pictures there you go to
the bottom left there you go okay that
might be the first ever Manhattanhenge
photo what is that from I took that in
2001 right - and it got published in
2002 before September 11th this is July
I took it before September 11th right
right and then I had a means to publish
it and right then the notice that it's a
green light and traffic is ready to
knock me over so so no one is in the
streets doing this but now there are
tens of thousands of people that pour
into the streets on these days we post
what day you're getting Manhattanhenge
from the American Museum of Natural
History my day job and then that goes
out the press gets it and tens of
thousands of people spin with the street
blocking traffic and if you think of all
the ways traffic gets blocked in your
day yeah it was too many of them by
yourself it's interesting it's great
yeah so that's what it'll become holding
up phones but it's all because I went to
Stonehenge yeah so it's a it's also a
observatory so this was it you that
named this yeah yeah damn check you out
coins coins I think say coined it yeah
Manhattan hinge because the buildings
are like hinges the hinge is a stone is
a vertical stone there's a vertical
structure if you made a stone it's a
stone hinge why isn't it possible to
construct a calendar that doesn't have
leap years what you would have to do you
could do it but what would happen is it
means you care more about the year than
you do about the day so what would
happen is you would celebrate the New
Year at like 3:00 in the afternoon
right and then the next year you've
celebrated at like 12 minutes after 3:00
in the afternoon and then 20 minutes you
would you would it would sort of move
through your calendar and then that
means you cared more about the year the
Atari you care more about the til I say
that right you we always want to
celebrate New Year's on midnight of the
and by the way New Year's is celebrated
in 24 time zones not all at the same
time right
so it's interesting everyone thinks of
that as a moment hmm yeah it's really a
calendar event I'm sorry it's a [ __ ]
event it's celebrated over 24 hours yeah
if you're in Thailand it's 14 hours
different so therefore if you were to do
it astrophysically you would know the
exact moment where we returned in our
orbit and everybody would celebrate that
instant mmm and that would be so then
the whole world would celebrate the New
Year at the same time that it means you
value it differently it's not a midnight
celebration it's a you could do that I
know less Jill so it's a celestial
yeah huh so that would be the only way
yeah that's the only way because a day
doesn't cut evenly into the year that
those two have nothing to do with one
another
there's no reason why that would have so
we we we so in other words let me say it
another way just because you're looking
like you're like you're looking off in
space here so there's New Year's okay
let's count 365 days when we do that we
are not at the same place we were when
we last celebrated New Year's Day New
Year's Eve okay we're not the same place
in orbit a revolution around you rotate
on an axis you revolve around something
else as those two words okay how you use
those two words so we're not in the same
place but we celebrate New Year's anyway
well when will we be in the same place a
quarter of a day later six hours so we
would celebrate the next New Year at 6
a.m.
nobody's won those will end in the next
New Year at noon then the next year at 6
p.m. and then the next New Year kind of
aligns back again well that's the leap
day
the fourth year were you put in a later
Oh see so it's our love of the day yes
that keeps us yeah
[ __ ] up with the world and it comes to
the year yeah wow you pick one and then
that's how that's how you do it and what
the minds base it on the moon right I
didn't I didn't study their calendar as
deeply as I should have and wanted to
especially back in 2012 and everyone
said oh the Mayan calendar runs out so
therefore it's the end of the world I
was thinking because the Mayans said sir
the Maya sets out like that was back
when you know before that had happened
it was you know George Bush was
president in like 2007 and everybody was
thinking Jesus this is this is gonna be
the end oh they're so what so every
decade there's somebody predicting the
end of the world sure I'm actually quite
entertained by this exercise do you
member when they had billboards all
around okay just what years know that
that's a different end of the world
that's that's a guy with a radio podcast
Church then yeah and then the underworld
didn't come and so you pushed it forward
so that's it's entertaining we live in a
free country it's evidence that we live
in a free country where freedom of
speech is protected and you can practice
any religion you want right that's and
they didn't learn much science in school
that's a part of it that's part of the
fact that you have this in our world
I don't mind it actually I find it
entertaining but it becomes an issue if
people such as that gain power over
legislation over the rest of us because
this would counts this as a personal
belief it's your personal belief the
world is gonna end on October 19th in
the that's your present you you're in
fine right you but if you now create
laws that require I go with that you
just impose your personal belief on me
and your personal belief is not true for
everyone it's only true for you yeah
that's a problem and an objective truth
is true for everyone so if you're gonna
have if you're gonna have governance
you're gonna want to base governance on
what is objectively true
because it would apply to everyone
independent of your belief system hmm
yeah I agree with that and by the way
there there there there there are things
that we're not sure or true yet that
we're still researching that's not what
I'm talking about as an as an objective
truth check your truth have been
verified by multiple scientific studies
not just one study this was the problem
with the the cholesterol study there's a
cholesterol study that said everybody on
the course to drop their cholesterol
levels okay
saying it would be good for your heart
and all the rest of this because a
series of countries were studied where
they have longevity and low heart low
heart disease and low cholesterol intake
that study happened to leave out France
that happened and it just wasn't in the
study and a couple of other places that
have high cholesterol intake but don't
have higher heart disease so that study
was flawed but it was hard to replicate
it because it went over many years and
it was thousands of people and so
everyone just jumped on it you don't
have a scientific truth and this this is
a general problem with medical results
because the press is waiting at the at
the at the journal editors office oh
here's a new study that shows that this
gives you cancer oh that must be true
and out comes the headline because you
want to be the first to report it mm and
then that gets emblazoned in people's
heads and not everyone reads the
follow-up no one could duplicate that
study know what so there's a flaw we
don't even know what the flaw is we know
that no one else could get those results
so it goes in the dustbin of scientific
research most research in any Journal of
the moment will ultimately shown to be
wrong
that's the bleeding edge of science it's
a it's a great place to be because
you're in the you're in the trenches and
you don't know what is true you can't
look up in the back of the book what the
answer is to double-check you don't even
know what the question is to ask half
the time Oh
but it's very frustrating for people
that don't get it and correctly but it's
excited it's exciting for the science
it's exciting to acknowledge ya period
it's constantly expanding and growing
but it's very frustrating for people
that really don't have the time and you
know maybe did get some outdated
nutrition knowledge what they need an
answer no they didn't answer right Yeah
right now and and religion in many ways
gives you answers right now yeah without
the need to sort of research it or to go
on the frontier the lack of education
and the lack of the lack of curiosity
about is one of the scariest things
about new generations of kids right like
when the new generations are coming up
if they know less than the generation
before that's when we really start to
freak out that would be a problem
although I have good confidence in the
30 and under is that millennial I how
will you have to be I think Millennials
have only ever known the internet and
devices so recent but my son is a
millennial and he's like my kids are
Millennials so they're 20 ish so not 30s
a little old so 25 and under I think are
the Millennials
yeah but 30 when they were 10 the
internet was around I know but they need
a different marketing term so you can
market to them differently
yeah so to me I would put them in the
same bin just as you were thinking there
but but they they have a different
relationship to Science and Technology
of course they're not they don't fear
the science or the technology they
embrace it because it has shaped the
civilization that has enabled their
social life it has but through this like
one of the things that I tweeted I think
it was from Scientific American
yesterday maybe was yesterday that it's
a little bit misleading but one of the
things they said is only 64 percent of
Millennials have a strong belief these
things these coasters are terrible they
look great but then things stick to the
but how was it made of metal okay a
metal coaster yeah see the hell is that
sticks yeah that's the issue sticks when
it gets moisture you know about this we
flip this over and you tip it over and
then it whatever done that you know what
yes yeah oh because the pressure you
have the air pressure
okay but don't do it okay
subjective truth 64% of what of
Millennials are not our only 64% are
convinced the world is a ball the world
is a circle that lures us what is this
fear oyd so what it's called oblique I
mean I'd like to see how that question
exactly because if they know that we are
oblate and the thing is asking is earth
a ball they'll say no we're in a blatant
ball I'm slightly wider below the
equator than at the equator so we're a
pear-shaped oblate spheroid but it's not
a pair that you would find normally if
you found that period but this if I
compare the shape like a ball so the
these distinction these differences and
measurements are so small that if you
found it on the ground you would say
this is a perfect sphere right let me
tell you how this how good a sphere it
is right all right you ever see the the
schoolroom globes the the Geographic
globes and you rub your finger over
Nepal and you get the mmm the Himalayas
yeah and you get the Rockies and so that
is a gross exaggeration of reality yes
do you realize if you took earth with
all of its mountains valleys and hills
and met and shrunk it down to the size
of a cue ball it would be smoother than
any cue ball every machined yes yes
think about it what think about this Joe
really generous Joe Chill listen to me
right okay uh do you know the deepest
part of Earth's crust no the Marianas
Trench off the coast of the Philippines
in the Pacific Ocean that's the deepest
part deepest part goes six miles down
okay okay so okay without doing thinking
of the depth
sorry crust exact oh no no just access
to the deepest part of risk crust the
lowest point on earth surface the
Marianas Trench right off the coast of
the Philippines the highest point on
earth surface the tip of k1 k2
okay 132 this is Japan
I think it's k1 what why would you name
the tallest peak k2 it's a good point
I'm
all right I'm not a mountain climber but
I'm I'm just thinking where's k1 okay
with it's the Himalayan mountains okay
in Nepal okay isn't it in Nepal I think
it is yeah yeah okay so now let's say
how high up is that was 28,000 feet so
it's like five miles up okay right the
distance between the lowest point on
earth surface and the highest point on
earth surface is 11 miles that's here to
the Comedy Store that is less than the
length of Manhattan Oh
yet we are 8,000 miles in diameter and
those two points are very far separated
from one another if you are cosmic giant
and you came up to earth and you rubbed
your finger over Earth's surface it
would feel as smooth as a cue ball to
you Wow in fact in this in this book I
have a whole chapter called on being
round which is all about this it's all
about our perception of what is round
and what is not I had asked you to
debate want them Flat Earth guys no I
don't I can't I'd no no we talked about
it and we're gonna have a month I know
what we do is and I think this is a
diabolical plot so that the next time we
can ship people on mass into orbit they
all want to be the first in line because
they know we're gonna send them so if
they can see the round earth they're
gonna be the first ones in space just so
they can stop annoying the rest I do
have people that have met that don't
believe because they the problem with
YouTube videos is it's a problem with a
lot of things but one of the things
about being unchecked while you're
discussing things is you can say things
you can use big words you can sound
articulate and smooth and you can do it
in a very professional-looking manner or
do it passionately yes passionately
convincingly charismatic ly and you
you're unchecked but if you did that in
front of an expert and you showed them
that along the way they go stop that's
not true stop that's not what works
right let me show you why this is
incorrect let me show you how you can
prove the
this is incorrect show your objective
truths but this is not happy to render
your argument invalid so people don't
have any education and then they watch
one of these YouTube clips they start
actually believing that this stuff makes
sense because it's unchecked and I would
say it's not about whether they've had
education it's about whether the
education they had teaches them
skepticism of information and teaches
them how to inquire you realize it's
just as intellectually lazy to believe
everything you see as it is to deny
everything you see yes why should
someone know automatically that earth
isn't flat yet I tell them in the next
breath that the entire universe was once
as small as a marble right both of those
sound cool a preposterous except one has
evidence to back it and the other does
not
and very strong scientific theoretical
and experimental underpinnings so when
you are trained to inquire you don't
either believe everything outright or
reject everything outright you're
trained to ask questions you're trained
to probe deeper than the layer of
information that comes to you that's
what should be taught in school and it's
not they give you a book and say learn
this yeah and you'll get tested on it
and then when you're done learn this
well listen also there's a problem with
being in X or oblique connected to your
first belief do you when you have an
idea and it's in your head it's very
difficult for people to shake that ID
and they start arguing that idea that
idea becomes a part of their identity
and they dig their heels in deeper an
opposing view is presented because they
connect themselves to these ideas right
it's it is who they are right right and
so I I try not to base my character
profile on something that is not yet
verified as objective truth and that's a
very good thing to do it's one of the
reasons why I don't have tattoos on my
body but stretch in my face go on one of
the reasons is there's nothing I am so
sure about
that I want to put it indelibly on my
skin well no no that's not let me say
differently there's nothing I value in
my mind body and soul so much in this
moment that I want to indelibly etched
it on my skin because I want to leave
room for me to have a possibly more
enlightening thought later mmm that
would override whatever was my decision
in that moment and since I count myself
among the lifelong learners I'm learning
stuff all the time they say wow that's
good I didn't know that well that's even
better what's something you learned
recently so you went oh okay let me let
me think hmm okay or something I learned
recently I think I knew this when I was
a kid but if you're playing basketball
and you're shooting okay and you say oh
that didn't go in oh my gosh well you
know the rim they should maybe make the
rim a little bigger IQ score more often
do you realize two basketballs can fit
exactly side by side through the opening
of a basketball hoop hmm really
yes I guess that makes sense two
basketballs top squeeze no it's not a
cosmically mind-blowing moment but that
gives you perspective next time you
watch a basketball game
it's how these guys can fly from the
from the foul line in a in an airborne
slam dunk and not miss because the area
of this opening is four times you do the
math it's four times as large as the
ball itself right because of the
different positions it could be so
they're multiple positions and they can
still do it
so it's not that that's easy to
accomplish but knowing this you realize
how much easier it is to score than you
might have otherwise thought I wonder if
basketball so that was a recent that was
a recent revelation that's a good
revelation yeah I wonder if basketball
players occasionally practice with a
smaller hole I think about this all the
time I said if I was a basketball player
you don't want to practice with
everyone saying yes because that venue
would that would throw the water off
your enjoy your practice with this and a
bigger ball they use a bigger ball we
use a ball sometimes it's almost as big
as their wait a minute is it heavier no
no no no you don't know you don't use a
bigger bowl it's a thing they did a long
time ago I bet they still don't they no
longer do it because then your grip is
different the grip has matters right
where your two hands go and what they
feel yeah so you want to do it you use a
smaller rim and in baseball you throw a
faster pitch to give you less reaction
time there a skinnier bat the pool table
is a very small pocket opening nice four
inch pocket opening is opposed to a five
and a half inch so it's quite a bit if
you're doing it you're doing it and so I
would also you know growing up I played
stickball in the street in New York and
so you're using basically a broom handle
and so when the first time you play
baseball officially it's like whoa yeah
I've got this huge bat and so stickball
players tend to transfer very well to
baseball when you're a kid yeah because
your instrument is bigger it is your a
the talent code no Daniel Coyle know one
of the interesting parts about it is
Brazilian soccer players how good they
are and they he attributed to a
different game that they play with a
heavier ball that they do indoors it's a
small heavy ball and because they do it
in tight quarters it involves incredibly
fast footwork okay and movement and then
these guys take that footwork and
movement and it translates amazingly
well to an open soccer field I wonder if
they calculated that because what you
would do is let's say the ball weighs
twice as much then it would only go half
as far when you kicked it so then you
make a field half as large I don't think
they did then you can reproduce almost
all of the dynamics of the soccer game I
think it was based on just trying to
play games like how far you can rub it
in over if it's balls twice as heavy you
throw it half as far the field is half
the size right and then you have a mini
game they survive right that makes sense
there's a whole fun exercise you can do
playing sports on other planets with
different ground it's a very very fun
thing to do if you're a dork
you know it's funny occasionally I'll
tweet something and people say dork and
I say yeah thanks for the compliment
okay it's already a bath it used to be a
dork as well
you give wedgies to the Nerds yeah well
the Nerds would also be the people that
were like but now a nerd is like you can
be a science nerd and people like it
that's a go yeah yeah I'm an old movie
nerd you can say that yeah or movie geek
yeah taking dork okay taking dork and
nerd yeah take that I tell you I must I
must have told you this last time I was
on your show when I was a kid I was
bigger than other kids I was always one
of the tallest two kids in the class out
of 30 so I was bigger than others in the
day and I was also physically fit and
physically active athletic but I was
squarely in the geek camp okay I had my
slide rule back in the day walking down
the corridor you know you were also
wrestling I was captain in my high
school's wrestling team so I was a geek
person who could actually kick your ass
okay and I saw how my fellow geeks cuz
that's the community that I so seen
card-carrying were treated by the
football quarterback and the popular
kids and the kids who are all beautiful
and the ones who and I imagine my future
as a superhero defender of the geek so
that you put up a little you know bat
signal whatever geeks they don't put a
few digits of pi and I come flying in
and there's a wedgie in progress right I
would just land and I grabbed the the
bully and and ripped them off the the
encounter and I've just saved the day
this is my superheroes always the
football players right always it's all
because there's I think they're rewarded
for violence for violence they also have
brain damage weekly as we've come to
discover how [ __ ] up is that you find
out high school kids right literally
across the board the majority of people
who play football have CTE right
in as far down as seventh-grade yeah
what yes et remind me that's Texas for
um chronic traumatic encephalopathy
[Music]
encephalopathy dot yeah say like Mike
Tyson alpha P so let me tell you that
story about Christopher Columbus please
so the dick story told you the dick
story yeah now let me tell you just
something else okay okay I think him
coming to America was the most
significant thing to ever happen in our
species whoa silence not an internet
porn no that's just porn in another
medium right Wow yeah so yeah internet
porn is just a matter of degree not a
matter of yes does it exist or does it
not right okay I think it was a most
significant event to happen in our
species kind of amazing when you stop
and think about the fact that at that
point in time other than the Native
Americans who lived here who living a
nomadic tribal existence very few people
that had the wheel that had firearms
that had all these things that had
already been achieved in the rest of the
world had made their way to this place
so don't watch okay here's how it worked
right so you're gonna hear so I that you
have some skepticism of this claim as
most people would especially the the
Columbus haters who are out there all
right now I don't really have any okay
so let me let me describe to you why I
think this is true okay and then you can
tell me whether you agree or not all
right we are hunter-gatherers we haven't
settled down yet the early humans and
we're basically wandering we're
following the herds alright and then the
ice age hits well what is an ice age an
ice age means it is so cold that when
the moisture evaporates from the
goes to the clouds the clouds go over
the land it doesn't rain it snows and
the snow falls and then it stays so the
water that had lifted up from the ocean
does not return to the ocean it
accumulates on the land and this
accumulation when it's significant and
sustained we call glaciers glaciers is
not itself a snowfall it is compressed
snow that's basically change state into
this this ice river that flows very
slowly back to the ocean but the oceans
are getting drained faster than they're
getting replenished so during the Ice
Age the ocean levels dropped exposing
the Bering Strait land bridge between
Asia and what is now Alaska basically
North America the our ancestors who come
out of Africa go into Europe some stayed
others kept wandering some stayed low
above the Mediterranean others went high
they populate Asia they keep walking
because there's a land bridge there they
don't even know it's a bridge it's just
more land so they walk and they enter
North America from there that's kind of
only way you can go with South at that
point the weather gets a little better
the Ice Age ends the glaciers melt back
into the oceans the oceans level ocean
levels rise closing the land bridge
stranding a branch of the human species
for 10,000 years those humans who made
it across that land bridge and spread
out into North America Central America
South America have only a few families
as their parent genetic as their genetic
origin okay oh it's like that some
research says it's like eight family
lineages populated the entire north of
South American
countenance then the land bridge breaks
now you have Europe Asia Africa and
North and South America and they know
nothing of one another two separate
branches of the human species
the Vikings notwithstanding maybe they
found came over they didn't time that
even if they did their influence was
near zero relative to the Europeans so
we're talking about influence here this
is a branch had this continued this is
how you specie ate this is why the
species on Australia that's why you have
mammals there would they have pouches
all right no other mammals do that they
split off and they evolved their own way
okay so ten thousand years is not enough
to grow three heads or you know twelve
fingers but our species is separate now
Columbus crosses the Atlantic makes
contact with humans this is the first
time that has happened in ten thousand
years we have rejoined two branches of
the human species we are now one common
genetic group and that genetic
crossbreeding and that continues to this
day we fly to any corner of the world
and mates okay and the mating already
began immediately yes there were
diseases that Columbus brought to North
America much written about that less
written is that he brought syphilis back
to Europe first cases of syphilis of
1492 whoa and then it yes what did they
have no problem with it well yeah I
don't know the details of how the
physiology of the natives huh
dealt with that or whether it mutated
you know I don't and there may people
know that I'm not among them that's fast
but if just look at you look at the
graph of syphilis reported syphilis
cases in Europe it all began 1492 when
he came back so what I'm saying is this
was a hugely significant event the
rejoining of the branches of the human
species but ya know I would imagine that
that makes sense that is the most
important
and by the way Native Americans you know
this famous infamous problem with
metabolizing alcohol okay with Native
Americans you know where else has their
problems the Chinese they do yes yes yes
so it's an Asian issue well so who
stayed in it so you look at who
populated North and South America after
the you know before the landbridge is
whoever was right at the edge of Asia
right then the land bridge is so-so
Asians and and North American and and
the natives of North and South America
have more in common with each other
because of this then most other pairs of
groups you might grab around the world
but my point is obviously we there's a
lot to blame Columbus for but he just
happened to be the guy who did it first
Europe was coming to the new world no
matter what that everybody was trying to
find a faster trade route to the Indies
and so if what if it wasn't Columbus it
would have been Arnold's Mednick or
whatever it doesn't matter
somebody did that and the rest is as
they say history Wow
so personally I think it's the most
significant thing to happen in our
species otherwise we'd still be two
stranded branches of humans it would be
fascinating though like Australia
stranded to see what would happen if it
this has gone on for hundreds of
thousands of years hundred thousand that
would have been a different story right
yeah and your immunities would be
different your yeah well that's the big
concern about aliens right one of the
big concerns is that there's some sort
of a virus you pick up from somewhere I
think that's harder to accept so for
example what are the chances that a oak
tree would catch whooping cough not so
good we're two different species so
viruses tend to be very species targeted
yeah but what about species sure they
can jump species but so there's a jump
mammal to mammal does it vertebrate to
vertebrate but so yes that can happen
but the more different the life-form is
it is sensible to suppose that the less
likely
you're gonna share the same diseases
that's all but NASA regardless has
safeguards in place in the event that
that happens so it's it's called the
planetary protection program the NASA
it's got as a whole division of masks
it's protecting Earth from bugs that
could be coming from space on our own
spaceship that we bring back and it
protects destinations from us there's a
certain sterilization levels that we
invoke the Cassini spacecraft we plunge
that back into Saturn in its death when
we were done with it and ran out of
money we're done with it plunged into
Saturn to vaporize we didn't leave in an
orbit around Saturn why because it might
have crashed into one of Saturn's moons
that might have life and if someone had
sneezed on the spacecraft before it got
launched we don't want to contaminate
the life that we were later gonna one
day want to study so that's what so we
plunged it into Saturn that's why that
is why because they were worried about
let maybe in hitting Europa once it's
dead and you can't track it or guide it
anymore then it's a it's a while it's a
wild card it might hit your Europa is a
moon of Jupiter but yeah Enceladus there
are other moons that have sort of ocean
water their water world's basically and
so the concern is that we would
introduce life suppose we did it crashed
and then we go back later and find life
and it has DNA just like here but was it
our life that we contaminated with that
you don't want to confuse the future
science of it so that's a that's the
plan
can you even watch a science movie like
science fiction movies I know you had a
real problem with gravity boom yeah
alright so I let me set the record
straight here okay I mean let me just go
on record okay okay I've been deeply
misunderstood with my comments on movies
deeply misunderstood deeply deeply and
so I've just stopped most last time you
saw a movie comment in my Twitter stream
we haven't you haven't I've kind of just
stopped wasn't the Matthew McConaughey
movie did you comment on that one oh
interstellar just oh that's the last one
I commented on
a big way right you've done yeah I'm
done because people then thought I've
just being nitpicky I did one it's not
fun going in movies with you yeah why
would you do that Tyson will just say
that can never happen and so so my
intent was my intent did not match how
people received my intent my intent is
here's an observation that I think if
you understood this it would enhance
your appreciation of the movie let me
give an example please do Star Wars The
Force awakens they've got one was that
that's the one with that introduced a
bb-8 okay that's the most recent no no
no this is like four movies ago now plus
I've lost track because there's another
one okay so the one to introduce bb-8
cutest cute as ever
okay our cute little fella and in there
they have their like the the updated
Death Star right okay remember the old
Death Star has enough power to destroy a
planet and that's devastating this one
it can suck energy out of a star so that
the star no longer exists
hmm then it could take these energy
beams and kill six planets at once it's
no longer just a one planet killer six
or eight whatever the number was it was
like high single digits okay well I did
the math on this and I tweeted and I I
said first okay they did take all the
energy from a star you become a star but
let's not maybe they've got a
containment mechanism I'll give it to
them it is the future after all honey is
the future but what a long time ago in a
galaxy far yeah that's another another
another universe of civilizations
okay mass but they have Lightspeed and
we don't so it's the future of our
technology even if it's the past of our
time so so you do the calculation and I
forgot the number but I got I calculated
how much energy is stored in a star
that's enough energy to explode a
thousand planets oh my gosh they under
represented the energy that it sucked
out of the Xhosa tar out of the snow
hmm and I thought this could have been
more badass than even they came up with
in this movie that is the nature of my
comments mmm not what could this happen
could it not happen let me give you a
perspective okay well so so 20% of
people just get pissed off 80% really
liked it and they want more but that 20%
they they cut me no slack and I'm only
doing this for people to enjoy and if if
I have that level of hate mail I don't
need to continue it I'm sorry to
basically stop I just thought to myself
but I don't have the urge to share them
I still have the thoughts I gotta teach
you the art of post and drop okay this
is what you do you post something know
people gonna get mad you drop your phone
and you walk away do that man can't be
reading those [ __ ] comments not it's
dealing with too many human being no I
got that I get that but but you don't
because you're still changing your
behavior here's my morons here's my
rebuttal your rebuttal my rebuttal is if
you're watching a movie that takes place
in 1958 it's a period piece and there's
a car from 1960 oh yeah and I'll be
crazy and someone who's a car expert
points that out you say hey he's an
expert that's pretty good
do you complain that the person noticed
that no you praise their expertise I get
mad at the movie if you get mad at the
movie if you're watching a Jane Austen
period piece and as 1870 whenever they
took place and someone gets out of the
carriage with tie-dyed bell-bottoms you
would cry foul right that would take you
up I'm exaggerating there obviously
could be a top hat instead of a derby
you would cry foul if you were a costume
designer and we would all be impressed
by that level of knowledge that you
exhibited mmm-hmm I am bringing a level
of science to bear on a movie that is no
different from anybody else's expertise
who is out there that we have praised
for that invocation yet people are not
granting me that latitude to make those
comments I don't like these
generalizations I don't like this is
true
but I don't like your saying people are
not doing this now a small vocal
minority that are [ __ ] and those are
the people that you're altering your
behavior for that's what I think is
ridiculous about them no because my
people would enjoy it when are you
talking about gravity and the fact that
hair wouldn't do that and the space
stations weren't that close together
right right you'll see it in the sky
right right but but it's [ __ ]
no I my tweets or offerings not but I'm
not that's the problem the only problem
is you're reading responses no you're
doing is wonderful
no one's getting people 20% freak out is
high for that [ __ ] is 20 listen hey I
don't believe those numbers here man I'm
alright when it's 5% then I take notice
but you say 20% like what are you doing
calculations you actually do know I scan
a hundred of them I see 20 of them
that's just run into 20 [ __ ] so 20
[ __ ] out of the millions and
millions of people that father you have
decided to reach out and and you're
altering your behavior for [ __ ]
I like those quotes I like when you when
you when you break things down because I
didn't know those things and I like
thinking about like the hair and gravity
I was like oh yeah the [ __ ] [ __ ] be
standing straight up and the only reason
why I mentioned about here cuz every
photo of anybody with long hair when
happened to you but it was long here in
space it's standing up on edge it's it's
a completely obvious thing that was
omitted from the filming of gravity yeah
but you have to have hair and makeup
they have to have a reason to exist so
so what I might do I might take a poll I
might put it by my puzzles I'm a servant
I don't wanna force feed curiosity have
to listen on your feed anybody force
feeding anything you pretty offerings
out there like you said there's not
force feeding you're not knocking on
someone's home wake up [ __ ] read my
[ __ ] that is true I'm not forcing myself
on your property put the shotgun down
you're gonna hear me talk about your
movie listen man I said about bb-8 I
said first I said BBS way cuter than
r2d2 and I use like five A's in the way
just to just to start a fight because
that's a fun fight right then I said by
the way
artoo bb-8 a smooth metal rolling
spherical ball would have skidded
uncontrollably on sand in the whole
movie is moving around on sand right
yeah it would that's why you deflate
your top that's why you deflate your
tires to drive on Sam
that's correct Wow have you ever tried
riding a bicycle on sand it's impossible
to get pong I'd imagine that and that's
with rubber tires imagine steel tires
you're not running on sand dune holy oh
my gosh oh yeah well the hardest things
you do for talked about getting into
shape yeah so it will work if you have a
hard surface just below it a dusting of
sand right then you course yeah then you
can dig into it I've ended some
resistance and then connects to the hard
surface so I posted this and people say
you're ruining the movie for me you're
and then people start [ __ ] again
when you say people you're just
listening to [ __ ] smart people gonna
read that go oh yeah yeah this is stupid
it would roll around yeah I'm [ __ ]
things you track but red you know it
actually happened as a result I think
I'm getting phone calls from producers
oh there's a little bit of science we
want to make sure that you don't tweet
about so good you keeping them on point
as you know I might be most famous among
in movie commenting for the final scene
in Titanic okay now if you knew about
this what would you say about the we
know where the Titanic sank the
longitude the latitude yes we know what
time of day Oh to Mars so at the POV the
point of view of rose as she's looking
up deliriously to the sky there's only
one sky she should have seen and was the
wrong sky not only the left side of the
sky it was worse than it was worse than
that the left side of this guy was a
mirror reflection of the right side of
the scale did you call James it was lazy
because I call it didn't know repledge
back in 1996 I saw it when it first came
out I noticed instantly and because I
know the sky I this is what I yeah okay
so no reply five years later I bump into
him at a meeting nasa hosted a meeting
with some explorers and some scientists
i
brought it up to him and he says well at
the time I was not overseeing
post-production and that's when we added
that so I immaturely wanted to grovel at
my feet for forgiveness did you yeah I
wanted him to but that's not what
happened
so then five years after that I brought
it up again when I bumped into him and
then he said you know last I checked
Titanic Titanic has earned more than a
billion dollars worldwide imagine how
much more it would have earned if I'd
gotten this guy correct
that's a stupid answer from an [ __ ]
it was it should be tweeting you know so
so let's but that's an ego answer but
it's not the end of the story so so that
was okay I have nothing more I can say
here cuz he's right okay
no he's not he's right no it made it a
lot of money and it would have made the
same amount of money that's true but
that's not the point but he [ __ ] up
[ __ ] don't say how much money a week
later I got a phone call so hi I forgot
his name John Smith hi John how can I
help you is this the dr. Titus I said
yes he said I work post production for
James Cameron mm-hmm he's producing a
director's cut where he's adding new
footage and he tells me you have a sky
he could use yes
oh so the Centennial release of Titanic
released in April 2012 I mean oh yeah
that's right yes so there was a 2012 I
feel like you and I had this
conversation I think we might have we
laughs I just put this in context yeah
it's got so so he actually put in so he
did come through my so here's what
happened Seth MacFarlane calls me up and
said I'm making a movie about a talking
teddy bear and I need to know the sky
over a town outside of Boston in 1985 on
Christmas Eve looking north northeast
you got a sky I said I get back to you
half hour later I send him the sky that
was the sky that the kid wished on to
for Ted
came to life so Ted had the correct
Scott and Titanic did not so first on
first correcting these at Ted one
Titanic zero on that right so the point
is that people started thinking about it
and if the highest compliment I ever got
was Andy weir who wrote the Martian he
said to himself while he was writing the
novel he said because he's an engineer
so he has the fluency and he's also
knows how to write
he's right creatively he said if Tyson
were looking over my shoulder well would
he would he tweet about this or not and
so that put him on notice to make sure
that his calculations were accurate and
the Martian is one of the most
entertaining ly accurate explorations of
how to invoke science to not die that
there ever was so for me that was a very
high compliment and it was kind of worth
it all of the naysayers that to know
that that Andy weir came through on that
yeah so why stop well maybe maybe I'll
change I think you need to learn how to
post and drop just think about it like
this posted boom walk away walk away
just go do something else man you don't
need to look at that [ __ ] you don't need
to look at what people are gonna say
make sure that there's no typos that's
always like no yeah it is isn't it
amazing yeah I got a fat thumbs me too I
I care though I'm sure you do about what
how people can think about what I wrote
mm-hmm if it's a way that I had not
considered okay I like knowing it makes
me a better communicator when I'm in
front of an audience I'll know what
percent will think one way versus
another and I can modify what I'm saying
to be more precise and - as we say in
physics to reduce the impedance between
the signal and the receiver so that
there's a better match between the
communicator and the audience I
understand that but if you you surely
have told jokes that people just took
the wrong way oh yeah the right way they
just didn't like what I was so yeah yeah
but it's surely like you see the word
cuck in a response you know
versus an [ __ ] right there's certain
things you just see like your cook like
okay enough listening anymore now I know
what you are yeah right you see that
like you you spend all the time stare
the [ __ ] sky instead of filling the
blank those are just [ __ ] well I
have pretty thick skin so it's not that
it upsets me it's that I'm here to serve
you not to piss you off are you not
there to serve I'm an educator there's
some people I'm an educator they're
looking to get angry maybe I can bring
them around
you can't the arrogance of thinking that
you could fix thirty plus years of
worthless [ __ ] living with a couple
of tweets okay you know something I
don't even want to take you up on that
challenge cuz you're probably right I'm
telling you you got a lot you gotta walk
away but for most people myself included
in those most people I enjoy those
tweets so I don't want something here's
one so I tweeted something and somebody
responding to somebody else's tweet said
you know I don't really like Tyson he's
such he's so pompous mmm okay so so I
tweeted back to that person and I said
thanks for your note could you please
share with me the single most pompous
thing you've ever seen me do and he
wrote back you said damn you would have
to be reading my tweets what you now you
put me on the spot I can't think of
anything right now but overall I really
like your work I think put nothing
forward yeah that happens all the time
because people are just shocked that you
respond but plus there's people can get
into a stereotype mode where there's
though that person is that and therefore
everything then just decide that's the
legacy that I write right you can't
listen those people do smart for this
and other people said look the dude
wrote a book called Astrophysical people
in a hurry yeah you'd say how pompous is
that that's not right hello write your
science educator I interviewed on
Startalk yes you were one of my guests
but so too was Katy Perry
now you go there people get pissed off
cuz they they just cuz she's a nothin
add she's just pop cause I said she
wanted she wrote a song about boney and
alien and I wanted to find out what she
was thinking yes yes her song she is a
line about it which I'm making love to
it so there's always ways you can you
[ __ ] Russell Crowe a few times or what's
named Peters sorry Russell I don't get
brand Peters wrestle Pete is a good
friend of Mines like Joe what the [ __ ] I
don't I just come back from Italy oh
yeah very confused yeah my brains zoning
a little out of it out of it try to keep
you awake for your friend Russell no
sorry she [ __ ] Russell Brand say it I
didn't know I didn't think I didn't know
any of this
you're married I didn't know this so
he's like an alien is my point he's a
very odd duck oh I see yeah he's a he's
a brilliant guy but he's he's out there
and he'd be like one of those guys that
would be in men in black aliens that
they're tracking to remember that scene
in the headquarters there's a big right
we're going to cover alien yeah all
aliens yeah they're like Michael Jackson
was there people who just there's
something a little different about them
you know so there's people that really
do believe that that believe that
there's aliens amongst us again that we
learn a free country I'm fine
but well you know what happens evidence
at some point should matter but you find
out about like Russian agents that have
been living in like New Jersey for like
thirty years that's the whole premise of
the Americans Americans yeah well it's a
real story to me really has happened on
multiple occasions and so they wonder
well if the Russians willing to do that
what are the aliens want to do yeah so
just find me one yeah maybe there are
doing you open minded to that of course
oh my gosh know who doesn't want to meet
aliens II wish I would love to meet the
aliens they're gonna have technology
that we don't have o to compare notes I
wanna oh my gosh do you by the way in
the movie arrival with the which one
arthropod okay there's and there's two
arrivals well there's an earlier rival
with Charlie Sheen yeah that's a good
one too so this one is you know it's
like a septa Puss lands yes certain
freaky things would speak in ink okay so
we can ink right so ice so they sent a
physicist and an anthropologist not
anthropologist a a linguist and I
tweeted I said you know if aliens come I
would not send a physicist and a link
and a linguist I would send and a an
astrobiologist and a cryptographer man
but then the linguist got all upset and
they started piling piling on the
linguist PI yeah she's not a linguist
she was a what if it's ant if you're an
anthropological linguist ortho they all
are but you just look up the title what
her profession was but anyhow so so they
all piled up piled up that's that's fine
bollocks SAT because how many linguists
are ever shown in a film so this was
their time in the Sun it's a big moment
so I get it that's fine but they're a
couple of things so for example there it
is making these circles and they're
interpreting them but it's making them
on glass so how do they know we weren't
seeing them the mirror image of what he
was trying to communicate that that was
not addressed in the film but yeah I'd
want to meet the aliens as they did
there they brought the military of
course that it would be a likely fact
but because your protection is of
extreme importance but here this happens
in all sci-fi movies you go up to this
thing and you get lifted up against the
force of gravity at that point I would
just put down all my weapons because
stuff going on that's way beyond your
understanding of the laws of physics
yeah you know it's like pulling out your
pistol and shooting at the spacecraft
that crossed half the galaxy to to come
to you what are you doing yeah they are
clearly superior to you in ways that you
don't even know yet so just find another
way to do your talking rather than
sending bullets their way but isn't that
always the case in every film I mean
it's always part of the narrative is
that the the primitive people [ __ ] it up
for the advanced civilization that's
coming here too
buzzer yeah it's never been good for the
less technologically advanced
civilization ever ever ever yeah right
and going on right now currently and by
the way undiscovered tribes
not to sound pluggy but this one of the
profiles here is of Captain Cook ah just
a quick thing I've visited Hawaii only a
couple of times in my life one of the
times I saw Don Ho the show yes yeah oh
my gosh and he was like he only sat down
he was like big and heavy and old and he
died a couple of decades ago but hey
yeah Don Ho he just tells Hawaiian
stories and one of them was about
Captain Cook and heat that some want
someone asked about whatever happened to
Captain Cook you know how he replies he
says nobody's ever seen him he's making
things he's pickin Captain Cook of Lake
so his rumors are that he was eaten by
yeah Pacific island natives but that
happened to a lot of pirates so watch
what happens so the Brits and Captain
Cook to the South Pacific why well you
look at his marching orders it's oh
there's what's called a transit of Venus
that's going to take place visible only
from the South Pacific this is where
earth in our orbit and Venus it's in
orbit are such that when Venus passes
between us in the Sun it actually is
exactly between us in the Sun you can
watch it move this circle move across
the Sun surface and then look through a
device that device with it filters we're
fine okay so if you measure that you can
learn the exact scale of the solar
system so you learn deep scientific
knowledge about how far away the planets
are and how far away the Sun is from the
earth it was not known with precision
before that measurement was made so
Captain Cook goes on his voyage to do
this well it's a pretty expensive voyage
oh oh wait flip over the marching orders
Oh open the envelope while you're there
use these new navigation techniques that
use the Sun Moon and stars
and map every coastline you find and
bring that information back to us within
ten years of Captain Cook navigating the
South Pacific as well as the northern
coast of Australia and New Zealand
within ten years Britain took control
over those coastlines became part of the
British Empire hegemony at its finest on
the premise that he's observing
something about the universe but there
was a tandem role that he played I did
not know they knew that much about the
cycles of the planets that they could be
there they knew accurately they could be
part of the motivation part of the
motivation of knowing any of this was
navigation around the globe was
navigation how you gonna know where you
are on earth you can get your latitude
that's just the altitude the height of
Polaris the North Star above the horizon
and measure that at night you can wait
that long where do you know where you
are vert in longitude ships would would
be shipwrecked millions of dollars worth
of Commerce would be at the bottom of
the ocean because they didn't know where
coastline was and the only way you can
measure coastline is see if you have
good navigational tools and tactics
which involves a an accurate chronometer
a timekeeping device for your prick and
knowing what the Sun Moon and stars are
doing in your sky so the astronomer in
that day was crucial to the mapping of
the earth and whose mapping earth is it
just geologists for fun no it is nations
wielding power over regions beyond the
beyond their own coastlines and that's I
have a quote here that's where this
quote comes from I got a guy from
seventeen whenever I get here stood 1757
James Ferguson 1757 here's his quote of
all the sciences cultivated by mankind
astronomy is acknowledged to be and
undoubtedly is the most sublime the most
interesting and the most useful for by
knowledge derived from this science not
only the bulk of the earth is
discovered but our very faculties are
enlarged with the grandeur of the ideas
it conveys our minds exalted above their
low contracted prejudices oh I gotta
drop a mic on that here boom drop that
mic
so notice he lists mapping the earth
first then he talks about how it exalts
in our grandeur hmm so yeah it's an
exercise in dominance in hegemony in
power under the guise of studying well
it's not so much it's just they call
fate they did it together if they matter
to one another yeah I was part of it
it's part of it and they're using a
sextant for all this so sexton helped
there's an octant a little earlier the
people and the the Muslims used an
astrolabe okay you've got by the way
what's the number it's a third or two
but I forgot that the fraction around
1/2 of all stars that have names in the
night sky have Arabic names because in
the Golden Age of Islam a thousand years
ago navigation was a big deal and they
navigated using astrolabes which is sort
of the the the Islamic counterpart to
the sextant and the octant that were
used what is left of Europe a sphere
that relates a gorgeous Oh then they're
works of art their brass they're edged
there's righty I sell them you can buy
replicas but you know I can get original
see find astrolabe yeah yeah astrolabe
what that looks like oh yeah so there's
a there's a thing that hangs down there
are different discs that you can replace
depending on where you are on earth to
be to know where you are more accurately
so this is all navigation so that it was
almost like clips for a GPS device yes
they're gorgeous they're completely
gorgeous Wow what the [ __ ] you carry
them with found that somewhere you go
okay aliens a bit yeah yeah exactly if
you didn't otherwise you know you're
history look at this that's about the
size of a heavyweight champions Bell
buckle buckle bet so what is that thing
doing so yeah depends
where you are runners when you want
that's what I'm saying so this is we're
talking about this was you know a
thousand years ago say you know this is
seven hundred years ago six hundred
years ago five the Ottoman Empire is
spreading their influence and they've
got they've got astrolabes so this is
Islam did you don't even learn about
this in school could you only hear about
the rest of Europe Christian Europe so
this mask an incredible looking device
yes and these are dials that turn it
looks like underneath tattoo like
there's a rhyme or reason to it with all
the claws and everything it completely
looks like art it looks like some
bizarre looks like an alien yeah yeah so
again if you're only listening just just
google astral astrolabe and and then
look at any of them that's a primitive a
more primitive one was simpler one and
so that's 1602 so no so that one that
has the spirit of an astrolabe but I
don't know that if they would have
called that an astrolabe the others they
go way back and so the most decorated
ones are the ones from the Middle East
but anyhow the point is GPS is no
different from the navigation tools in
in concept from the navigation tools
that Captain Cook invoked for Britain to
then take control over all the South
Pacific that they did it is where are we
and do we know this information with
precision and so and what happens if an
anime force takes out our GPS and we
have so much dependent on it what are we
going to do
we've got people now worrying about
working on using navigation by pulsars
can't take those out because those are
cosmic they're sending highly time to
pulses that reach earth in different
places on the sky and by measuring them
you can and the time delay between one
and the other you can actually localize
yourself on Earth's surface with
extremely high precision and without any
use of satellites that's the future of
navigation where you were insulated from
a rogue nation that might want to take
out your satellites pulsars
pulsers and by the way the Trump space
force you know the many people whole lot
of Trump haters out there and but if you
want to hate Trump rationally you want
to not hate him no matter what he says
you want to evaluate statement by
statement what he says right that's what
you want to do he says I want a space
for us well let's think about that okay
in the Second World War there was the
Air Force except they were not their own
branch they were part of the army was
called the Army Air Force and then we
realized that command and control in the
air needs different kinds of soldiers
there because they have to be pilots
it's a different kind of decision making
different kinds of tactical actions you
would have in the in the theater of
operations and so it was sensible to
spawn off a new branch of the military
called the Air Force no one today would
question whether that was a good idea
today you should know that operations in
space in the vacuum of the universe is a
different regime that you're operating
in from moving through the air your
hardware looks different your your
strategies are different your decision
your command and control is different so
it's not a crate just because it came
out of trumps mouth doesn't make it a
crazy idea that you might want a space
force in fact I had proposed the space
force in 2001 when I was on a commission
appointed by George W Bush to explore
the future of the United States space
aerospace industry a commission of 12 so
I put it on the table we have Air Force
generals they're former members of
Congress people from Lockheed Martin and
people said well the Air Force is
currently overseeing space the United
States Space Command so everybody was
happy with it and so I find that's okay
let's not worry about it
if everybody's have but as if as long as
this needs of our presence and space
grows but more importantly the size of
our assets as long as that continues to
grow what else would a military do
beyond protecting your borders they
would protect your assets and our space
assets by day but day by day are growing
by leaps and bounds
so it's not acids meaning like satellite
satellite station and the value of those
it's not just the cost of the satellite
is the value that's at the satellite to
you right
the the military is now creating a whole
other GPS system that is will be
exclusive to them and then they're gonna
see the current GPS too and and what
have we done with GPS this hard-earned
engineering and physics and orbital
mechanics what have we done with the GPS
we now use it to find out who you want
to mate with Oh someone's in your area
yeah that's what this is tinder this is
Grindr this is show me may double people
within 20 square blocks of where I am
that's a GPS mate on Grindr I did look
at the definition mate mate implies
you're making a baby
yeah who you gonna have sex with fine
yeah yeah so so that has a certain
economic value to society in sodas uber
so do all the things that so does UPS
tracking their trucks yeah so it's not
the cost of the satellite it's the value
of the satellite to our economy you'd
want that protected make sense is there
a space force currently alig is it real
how they recruited the United States
Space Command so is there anybody who's
in general if we make a space there's
generals in the Air Force overseeing
Space Command so if you're gonna make a
space force you would offload you would
offload the space activities of the Air
Force Space Command to this US Space
Command primarily to the space force and
then add or subtract from that in
whatever way is sensible given the needs
if we have a space force you know what I
wanted to see what I want them to
protect us from asteroids how about that
for an offense program that makes sense
okay you want the government involved in
that shouldn't be someone a little bit
more thorough guess not how it works
it's not scientists yeah you you just
made you made a blanket anti-government
yeah Asian cuz you're just
anti-government guessing people say okay
so private enterprise is not good at
doing expensive things that have never
been done before right need government
money government government does it
first okay right then you learn where
the hostels are where the friendlies are
where
what patent did you need to make this
happen then the venture capitalists
meeting about whether I'm gonna make a
buck on it has some has some some teeth
in it they say how much will this cost
will we know because the government did
it and we think we can do it for half
that price is it dangerous yes the
government did this and they lost two
people but we will put protections in so
we won't have that risk what is the
return on the investment the government
got no return because they didn't that's
it wasn't the objective but here's how
we can bring so I'll do it second I
won't do it first this is how you get
the Dutch East India Trading Company
they were not the first Europeans to the
new world because where's the edge of
the earth will you find India where will
you get what you don't know any of this
I'm screaming at you sorry you don't
know any of this Columbus does it first
and he can tell you where there's food
and where this isn't where there isn't
and where they want to kill you and
where they don't then you hand that
information to the mark to the
mercantilist s-- and they make a buck
after the fact so they come in they come
in yeah that's how you do it that's how
modern airplanes came about people are
making planes in their garage the
government said this could be a cool
thing let's pay them and have them
compete to carry air mail new kind of
mail mail delivered by air oh that's
cool
so now I make an airplane cuz I want
that contract you say no you want the
contract you make an airplane that cat
has more cargo a bet better engine
you're cleverer now you just took the
contract from me now I make a bigger
airplane because I said oh I see what he
did there but now I can improve on that
now wait a minute I don't need to carry
mail I can carry people and thus is born
commercial yeah they're carefully the
government basically bankrolled it as
did as did prize money for accomplishing
certain achievements like Lindbergh no
one talks about the fact that there was
cash money available to him for having
done flown across the Atlantic solo
first cash money no kid yeah I did it
for the money yeah as most of them did
fly the longest the highest the fastest
each of these had money as
ciated with it so this drove the
marketplace it was not whether you could
make a product out of it initially
because you got to get over the early
humps you got to get through you got to
know what it is that works and what
doesn't so is there a plan with the
space force are they gonna make space
weapons and spaceships there's a treaty
in 1960s to which we are signatory
okay and I talked about in an accessory
to war it's again I hate I feel so bad
for doing this plug it baby no I feel so
let me hold it then no yeah you can you
hold it yeah yeah yeah I just feel but
it but it is the unspoken alliance
between astrophysics and the military
you look beautiful with that blank you
primarily because there is a bow and
arrow here other being shot by Senate
arias that became a weapon and a missile
at a tenure your bow and arrow guy yeah
last I checked yeah you've got a
freaking bow and arrow in the back room
here yes what are you afraid practice
when the zombies come run out of bullets
yeah I'm pulling this chick from Walking
Dead Oh seems to be the best weapon
everybody runs out of bullets right
zombies are slow and her weapon is in
fact this totally yeah so was I saying
before I interrupted myself space for
who's paying attention out there weapons
asteroid weaponizing space so this is
outer space trees but treaty for the
peaceful uses of outer space and it was
in 1967 there's some modification since
then but that's the basic one and we are
signature to it and so are the other
major countries of the world yeah didn't
we just break out of the Paris Accord
let's break out of that goddamn space
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's a beautiful document it
tries to be very forward-looking if
there's an astronaut from another
country who is at risk then you will go
to help them without question it's very
kumbaya okay so one of my sort of now
that I'm old and tired and I just I'm a
realist it's why should we promise to
not kill each other in space when we are
not
successful at doing that here on earth
and we don't even promise tonight
promise to do it here honor yeah
who are we to say oh well we'll kill
each other there but in space we'll all
hold hands maybe you know I don't have
that much confidence in human conduct
right I'm become cynical over my years
and I'm angry demonstrate to me that on
earth you'd know how to not kill one
another then I'll believe you're Space
Treaty so I'm saying here now
given that there is a treaty it says you
can't put heavy weapons in space as I
detail in one of the I'll by the way I
have a co-author on this I started doing
this twelve years ago and was like I
will never finish this for a thousand
years so I brought in a co-author office
Lang who is a longtime editor of my
essays that I written for Natural
History Magazine just give a shout out
to my co-author how does that work so
the in this case sort of takes your
stuff and stitches in this particular
case there's a lot of ways we
collaborated some of them I just
dictated entire chapters to her and but
leaving out certain details that would
require a nitty-gritty of sort of
research just to get the right numbers
in the right year and the right
commander and the right this but I know
broadly how it happened in what sequence
and so then she would take that in shape
that into a chapter other places I would
say you know this happened this happened
and that happened she would say well
that wouldn't fit the narrative as it's
coming together let's drop the middle
one and take the other two and I say
great so I'd write that up and she would
stitch it she would graft it is a better
word into the rest of what was going on
so this is even though there are places
here where I speak in first-person it's
actually it's a co-written project it's
not ghost written it's not I'm just
putting my name but somebody else wrote
I mean I write I know how to write so
we're co-authors on this but thanks for
asking
that was good so so the here's a problem
that we detail here people said I don't
want weapons in space okay there's
nothing more useless than a space weapon
relative to Earth's surface
okay if you're in space you're in orbit
take it through if I use your skull here
that's okay
okay if this is earth okay let's do
everything more spherical here I guess
not I'm using your skull so okay all
right so this is earth okay and I've got
a satellite in orbit around the earth
okay and I say okay I want to weaponize
the satellite put a bomb in it and I
want to drop over some city some some
bad person wants to make that decision
right well what's the city want it well
it's up here so I'm gonna drop it
halfway there so you got it well no it's
not just that these are not very high
above the planet and so you have to like
change the orbit to align it so that it
goes over your target satellites don't
go over every spot on earth right they
only go over the orbit that had print
preset for it okay we can already
destroy a city with an intercontinental
ballistic missile and we can aim that we
can aim a missile to any place on earth
and we'll get there
in less than 45 minutes and destroy the
whole city with nuclear weapons we can
already do that there is no advantage to
putting nukes in space if that's your
objective not only that suppose there's
a rogue satellite and it's messing with
you it's beaming energy particles at you
and you want to take it out how are you
gonna take it out you're gonna destroy
it oh now you break it into a million
pieces a thousand pieces
now each piece is moving 18,000 miles an
hour and put your own satellites at risk
that's the modern equivalent to in the
First World War when they said oh we
have a good idea because we can't shoot
them in the in the trenches let's gas
them out so they have the mustard gas
oops
the wind changed directions and all of a
sudden you become a victim of your own
weapon such as would happen in space if
you go in and start exploding satellites
out of orbit so war in space is a
different thing it's not what do you
think it would be so what would they do
so the outer peaceful use of outer space
treaty allows you to have defensive
things in space not offensive for
defensive purposes it allows that so
treaty aside though yeah what could you
do could you I mean could you have a
rogue state could take out our GPS
satellites okay but we render the
military
wine and then you won't be able to pick
up your uber you won't have anyone have
sex with tonight that's the range of
stuff that GPS applies to right and so
it'll affect our economy and will affect
our security and then our Navy can't
talk to the Air Force the Air Force
can't talk to it and that would be bad
mmm Army's up wars are no longer fought
just by how many soldiers have you lined
up at the border
it's what have you done strategically to
render your opponent just to render to
weaken your opponent or render them
incapable of fighting you this is why
the attacks on September 11th worked
because we had a policy that if someone
wants to hijack a plane you follow their
instructions you do not deny them their
requests because the assumption was that
if you deny their request they will
start harming people and if you follow
their requests it will delay when they
harm them if they harm them at all and
maybe everyone will end up safe it was
not in the game plan that they would
crash the plane on purpose
okay so September 12th you will never
again be able to do that to the American
plane forget the extra x-rays that we're
doing a pilot will never relinquish the
cockpit ever again no matter who they're
torturing in the back in the back of the
plane no matter what they're doing even
if it's shooting people one by one
because the plane going down takes
everybody out so that was a pretty easy
door to close literally and figuratively
but no one saw it coming you know it
drives me crazy when they put that drink
cart mm-hmm you know the hallway yeah to
protect the pilot and they opened I
asked them about that so it's just to
delay you a fraction of a second to give
them a chance to go in and lock the door
yeah right it's it's you have to get
through them and the flight attendant
that takes an extra second you can't
just run in plus you don't even allow
you to stand in the aisle while that's
happening tell you they said now if you
sit down correct so you have to get out
of your thing charge the cart and get
through the cart and
the flight attendant who will be
fighting for their life at this point
okay and because you're the plane is
everything right yeah I've seen that
opening no you can get through there
those ladies aren't gonna stop me Oh
nobody who really is physically Joe
Rogan I've already [ __ ] this through
well it's an unfortunate thing that my
mind does the point is you can I would
never do it of course you don't I I
thought about not that but I thought to
myself the plane that way because I was
like I witnessed September 11th four
blocks six blocks away from six walking
blocks for did you miss that plane hit
no because that was my view is blocked
from the south so but I have camcorder
footage of the explosion big explosion
I've ever seen
and by the way one thing I noticed is
that there was no shockwave I might have
been the closest scientist to the event
so I was all I could through was apply
every bit of physics that I know there
was no shockwave I said well how can we
have an explosion in no shockwave and I
later learned if you kind of make a
deflagration wave if you Adam I as fuel
and then you spark it then the flame
moves across the fuel it's not a it's
not a shockwave it's just a deflagration
wave and therefore there's no shockwave
and so windows are not blown out a
quarter mile away as they were in
Oklahoma City with the bomb with him
Timothy McVeigh we why am i bringing
this up what was I talking about
September 11 the plane oh yeah oh yeah
so here's something I calculated I said
if I was in a 767 and we're about to
crash into a building if I was in the
last row of the plane how much time
would elapse before the front row
crumbled and it met me in the back row
given the speed of the plane going into
the building 500 miles an hour yeah well
it's probably slower than that by then I
would say closer to 400 it's a known
speed and I don't know it but I don't
think it was because you can't turn at
that highest speed and it had to like
turn around in a name I say it's about a
second less half a fraction of a second
it's a fraction so the question is tiny
for how long does it take a plane to go
its own length right when it's going at
400 miles out yeah it's a fraction so
it's like that's it you can't even
process that so I figured the deaths
were pretty quick Wow instantaneous yes
basically instantaneous you are you are
pulverized pile of goo are they planning
on making spaceships that can shoot down
other spaceships so here so any space
wars would not be war between space and
earth it would be between stuff in space
that's all stuff in space like space
space yeah space to space yeah here's
another question they're gonna do with
all that stuff that's just floating
around up there the debris yeah how
about another task of a space force why
don't you clean up space for so that we
can have tourism and not risk our lives
by a paint chip or you know going 18,000
more bolt or nut moving at 18,000 miles
an hour that'll put a hole straight
through you Yeah right so yeah I would
like to see the portfolio of a space
force if there is a space force
broadened the scope of that to include
protecting us from asteroids and
figuring out a way to clean up the
debris of space is there a concept in
place no no no boy when you look at that
map but I know the map is not the scale
but it shows you the known satellites in
space oh well there it's it's to scale
in the sense that they're there there's
that many of them it's just as those
relative distance - but they have a lot
you can see their orbital line so it
feels crowded but it's it's so crazy
when you look at it it's just like like
it's just littered and we're continuing
to launch new things up there then I
joke I say one of the reasons why we've
never been tada a lien is because they
came to earth it what is all that junk
what oh we're not risking our lab let's
go to another planet yeah they didn't
know the map of where everything was
they had to calculate their income and
forget it they'll just take home it's
not worth it yeah I mean in when you're
on your way in you have to think about
it going around
you were visiting another planet that
had a civilization and they left a lot
of crap in their atmosphere you you
would yeah well those that's not the
debris that's those are the satellites
yeah so if you know that is debris no
you got it so so the the airforce tracks
debris as does NASA they both track
debris and sometimes launch windows of
spacecraft pieces of [ __ ] that's crazy
so we're so crazy we've only been doing
this for 60 years
so you track it right Mo's lost the
first satellite for sound Sputnik excuse
me what year 62 far away from you slap
you sorry
it was it Sputnik October 4th 1957 57
the first artificial anything in orbit
around the earth and on that day there
was only one thing one thing only Wow
from 57 to 2018 right so it's 60 years
Wow one thing that's crazy and now how
many things well there's the countless
debris there's hundreds of active
satellites there's thousands if you
include the dead ones and yes we have no
way to clean it up maybe it's some big
vacuum one day I don't know but yeah
space vacuum they'd have to be valuable
oh you know you could probably sell
space debris if you brought it back to
earth yeah people are dumb they'd buy it
speaking of debris speaking of debris
there was this asteroid that collided
with earth over chaya Binks in the
Soviet Union in Russia sorry
just near the Siberia in the Ural
Mountains just on the coast of Siberia
on the border of Siberia that was
visible to everybody in broad daylight
and he had to like avert your eyes when
it happened and they felt a shock wave
and the shock wave broke windows and
sent 600 people nearly a thousand people
to the hospital
what happened well because they saw the
light and they can't they got up from
their table and went to the window to
see what had happened there's a time
delay between the shock wave and the
light whose light travels fast and sound
travels slow so we'll go to the windows
and the shock wave hits and it blasts
broken glass into their face so it's a
big band-aid collision that we had the
injured people all needed basically
band-aids okay no one died but nearly a
thousand people were injured so at an
auction but that actually exploded and
pieces of it were recovered at an
auction I purchased a piece of that
meteorite but you know and also I
purchased some of the shards of glass
that the shock wave had broken what do
you do with this [ __ ] I've got it it's
just a habit
I'm on the part of it is a shot across
our bow that's what that no one died but
it's a warning there's no better way to
be warned than to have a band-aid cover
your injuries that could have vaporized
you or rendered your species extinct
what's crazy is the ones that don't even
make impact still do devastating damage
yes Tunguska yes that did that one
detach earth well right it incinerated
ten thousand square kilometers of forest
honk holy [ __ ]
yeah so if every 15 2013 and there is a
ways over a half a ton that Peter Rock
was a thousand pounds oh yeah holy
that's just a piece that made it through
is it iron well the actual piece would
have been about the size of this room so
a small home Wow
so that's amazing that that small rock
go back up to that again please
look at the size of that that's not that
no no that's what's left over most of it
except a per eyes on that on the
explosion as it came through the Atmos
right but they're saying that that piece
of it weighs a thousand pounds do they
give it the weight of it yeah okay he's
over a half ton yeah oh we have done
yeah a thousand pounds that's crazy
that rock is that [ __ ] heavy yeah so
it's soda so yes
well I have to read that to know for
sure but I think it was an iron
meteorite I'll tell you something would
I
a knife that was made out of a piece of
meat or as do I though the beautiful
hole yeah it's a kitchen knife that I
use Oh mine is like a it's like a
Crocodile Dundee knife oh yeah
though that's not a knife awesome ah
there's that's nice but it's waiting I
want to make a or get someone to make a
handle for it it's just that it's just a
metal that would be that would then
wedged for it's a forged metal with the
blade but then you get a pearl handle
attached to the base of oh yeah so it's
a handle this and it's an unadorned
piece of metal that would become a you
know the right oh yes sharpen oh yeah
where's the [ __ ] handle there is the
metal hey have you ever seen a kitchen
knives the metal goes all the way down
down the center of the handle and you
screw wooden handles on the sides so you
just need the wooden I just need the
wood or the or the if I'm patent they
would be purl you know yeah yeah purl
pistol yeah so so yeah it's part of
history and it's a reminder that if you
want to think about the future of
civilization you have to include a
defence plan against asteroids yeah
the dinosaurs dinosaurs I bet if they
could they would have had a space
program to not go extinct I wouldn't
know [ __ ] no is there anything that
we're doing now other than we're
occasionally looking up yeah we're
looking with monitoring and cataloging
them yeah but we don't really know what
to do yeah so happen the day would come
well we know what to do there's nothing
funded with their engineering
conferences how would you deflect an
asteroid
how would you destroy us we see one and
it's a we see one way and it's coming
100%
kiss your ass good-bye that's right we
would we would have the power to tell
you when you would die and what part of
earth it would hit yes people that have
very delusional ideas about what we can
and can't do with asteroids and that
drives me crazy
we know how did the scene the
engineering plans they look very good
but there's nothing in place right
there's project Sentinel you can look at
that is has tasked themselves with
organizing world governments to protect
Earth from species killing asteroids and
you need the world because you don't
know in advance until it's discovered
what part of Earth it's gonna hit and if
it's going to hit in the Indian Ocean
and if Indian if the surrounding regions
don't have a space program or if are the
countries that do have a space program
going to sit idle no what you want to do
is you want to have a fund and every
country pipes in a little bit of their
GDP and then or whatever but you know
you measure it however you want it
whatever you think is fair do it the way
the way the UN does it okay so there's a
tax of the world relative to your wealth
and then that money pays to save the
world when we find such an asteroid that
that's how the Sentinel project Sentinel
is is has thought this through
so if they're engineers and scientists
ample time there's possible there's a
possibility that they could actually
implement some of these plans it's all
about how much time you have because
what you want to do is go out and nudge
it alright a little bit if you a little
bit you just have to give it a sideways
velocity relative to its path towards
Earth if you do that early enough the
the sideways velocity sort of
accumulates right like ship turning
slightly over the ocean over the course
of time it'll deviate quite a bit
correct so that angle grows I mean it's
the same angle but the it spreads out
and if the the ocean example is perfect
is a perfect analogy so if you that
early enough you do it enough so that it
misses earth and it's still out there to
harm you in another day but it won't
render you extinct on that passage how
much time do we need today if I would
say we could probably get something
built in ten years oh no oh my gosh so a
year if we have a year the good thing
about species killing asteroids is that
they're large and visible what about
city killing ones them boulders slip
through yeah they'll slip through
yeah but most of Earth's surface is not
City so it'll probably hit the ocean or
land but yeah if it does it would take
out a city yeah there's a branch of
government part of I don't if it
survived the Trump changeover but it's
it's part of Homeland Security where it
worries about devastation to a region
where the grid is taken out as well so
you can't bring emergency services that
bring either food water medicines any
other form of transportation or
communication how much thaws there to
putting in a more robust grid I yeah
what you would need is that's that's a
good point
so you need a grid that can sort of
rewire itself rapidly to then bring
power to a region that's what you would
need and it would sort of doing that now
making a grid sort of lightning proof
you know power surge proof I grew up in
New York City where there were a couple
of very famous blackouts one in 1966
another in when was in 1978 I think and
there was like whoa how should this how
is this even allowed you don't have a
back-up plan yeah you'll have a way to
rewire this to redirect the electricity
so yeah you'd need that you'd want that
and I thought the new grid is supposed
to have those kinds of protections built
into it but I don't know enough about it
to comment is one one impact oh yeah one
big one yeah takes out the grid takes
out the grid and then what do you have
solar power at your place we just put in
that solar panels yeah
you lazy ever say that we have a place
in the country escape - yeah that's a
good move to have that escape spot yeah
you have a place in upstate New Zealand
yeah I used to think of it as an escape
because we thought of getting it after
September 11th got it in oh three oh two
something like that but now it's just a
good place for me to read
fuel and do a lot of good writing there
and they sort of thing look out for
ticks oh oh my god Long Island's
overwhelmed with London they got a new
tick apparently that prevents you from
eating meat
one of the vegetarians bread that think
it's followed the Lone Star tick and it
prevents you from eating the meat of
mammals yes it makes you allergic to
alpha galactose is that what it is it's
alpha gal another great radio lab
podcast yeah I died detail I think the
vegans and the vegetarians I think they
yeah I think you still eat fish
yeah not eat a mammal yes can eat red
meat it's something in red meat yeah
yeah so that's one of the challenges
yeah right goddamn ticks yeah they are
everywhere and we looked at it the other
day there's I have quite a few friends
that have Lyme disease and it's
something you do keep for life mmm and
quite a few friends like seven or eight
at this point that have devastating Lyme
disease and it's all East Coast people
yeah well they're making love in the
brush like what are they doing walking
around going for a hike yeah see I'm a
city person so even though I moved to
come I go for a hike on my deck no just
look out on the deck i but you're out
there in the this gorgeous country don't
you want to go wander around a little
bit
no no it's honestly not a thought my
wife from Alaska has those thoughts all
that but the power ticks overwhelms her
power of curiosity those are powerful
people in Alaska that's a different type
of yeah they're there they're there
they're bred differently oh they're
strong yeah those people can survive
yeah they're and they have a sentence a
unity up there it's really interesting
that unity I think comes from the fact
that they're all in the same risk
factors together yeah and if the if you
and I have the same things that can kill
us that makes us friends it's also
they're overwhelmed by nature it's like
they're overwhelmed by both its beauty
and just the sheer evidence that you're
insignificant I would say they're not
overwhelmed they are whelmed yeah
there's the right amount of whelmed I
have a buddy mine who lived up there a
grizzly bear killed a moose in his
driveway
like what right that's the kind of stuff
what in the driveway
they had to be careful like getting out
of the house Baird cashed the Moose when
we first went up there my brother-in-law
hurt my wife's sister's husband kept a
loaded shotgun over their bed so that
when the door starts rattling in the
middle of the night the the gun is in
his arms reach that was good that was
good
yeah those [ __ ] things you ever seen
one in real life
I mean zoo- not a real one real one
there's a there's a look they don't know
I did no no we visited Denali Park but I
saw it it's 500 yards away it's not
closer than that did not only Park there
a little bit habitual eyes too right
no it's really a while oh do you know I
confuse it with a Jellystone Park I'm
thinking of something different you
think in a Jellystone Park Denali Park
is where what's that near what part of
Alaska is in there it's got its got
Mount McKinley it's got Denali the
mountain right in it so Oh so where is
it it's I forgot geographically but
that's not like near the Brooks Range
right no I couldn't tell you I'm not I'm
not
mountain range this is sheer size of
Alaska when you actually look over the
United States know you can superimpose
it you know oh yeah what you want to
know another one don't know another one
yeah the size of Africa relative to
United States you've done many times so
excellent everything fits in there
everything fits like five United States
literally everything fits in there looks
like most of the world yeah that's in
there the United States plus Europe yeah
[ __ ] crazy
he's a giant place but uh what's really
interesting about Alaska is how few
people are there right you know I mean
it's such a large intensity yeah
population densities so light but but
Anchorage is a really cool City like if
you go there you're like oh this is a
cool last house yeah nice people but if
you go there in the summer bring some
things to cover your eyes oh when you go
into bed at night you're going to bed
today
yeah yeah it's yeah so so my wife said
in the winter when they go to school and
dark it's not nighttime just dark
yeah they don't use night and day it's
just our on light yeah because it's only
light for a few hours yes so that's
light and then it's dark you ever see
that movie was it called 30 days of
night vampire movie about Alaska no yeah
the vampires came to us actually I've
seen a pretty fun one in vampire movie
in mylanta like vampire moves I have
nothing against them just know that
smarts they don't talk to me they don't
I don't can't put that I don't see the
romance of getting bitten in the neck
Wow does that romance is scary actually
I think the the what's that stare right
series no no tell me you liked him the
other series underworld the under eyes
I've seen a few of those did you like
those that's fun those are the dumbest
ones know the Twilight fans make fun of
oh no I just like the fact that there's
a lead woman kicking ass those guys
women who could do your show I love
women
put on your little show love when women
are winning gasps no it's just fun well
then you must love alien the original
alien yeah talked about Ripley from
aliens Weaver
she's original female movie badass well
no no they go before and I just reminded
myself of this is it Barbara Rigg
Barbarella
no Barbara rig I think is her name she
was the woman and the original British
series of the Avengers oh yeah that's
true but that was hokey like but she was
wearing black leather that's a new
martial arts and kicked ass hmm wasn't
believable but whatever was believable
like like when she's shooting that thing
like you bought you buy it like looks
throwing this to me is like to you when
you're making fun okay mistakes that
they make in these movies about space
this [ __ ] drives me crazy people just
flipping people through the air and down
when they fly off buildings that stop
you driving me [ __ ] crazy actually I
have a tweet post it now it's too long I
gotta tell you one of those dangerous
guys doesn't put a case in your phone
you have the [ __ ] okay
Cape in your butt the back the on your
phone your lock screen is the Stonehenge
of Manhattan yeah yeah yeah yeah
Manhattanhenge no case in your phone no
you're a risk too
right no so you can think of it as
risk-taking
or when I got the phone cuz I admire how
thin this is right
I'd like technology yeah serving meek ok
so what I do when I got the phone I said
let me do this with it
ok lip it around yes and I reminded
myself why do in in the military cadets
why do they twirl their gun of what
possible value is this in combat why do
they do these things with their gun and
then I realized you're not supposed to
drop your gun ever hmm ever so if you
twirl the gun and you don't drop it
it means stuff can happen to you in
combat and it is always attached to your
body so I said so when I got my phone I
said let me just do this ok let me just
do this if I pick up the phone and so
when you do that then you never drop
your phone so it's not that I'm a
risk-taker it's that I've changed my
risk to make it so low that it is
essentially won't happen and you got
AppleCare know you didn't know your risk
take first I fix my own damn computer
second are you gonna fix your own damn
phone if the screen breaks you're gonna
get in there with a screwdriver and pop
that [ __ ] out put the new in the key
word the key phrase are there if the
screen break drop it
I also carry relatively expensive
fountain pens what happens with that I
never lose them oh I see what you're
saying if you always lose your pens
Amith you're not spending enough money
all right like sunglasses exactly bet
the same pair of sunglasses now for a
record number of time right cost you
$200 to get [ __ ] lose them they're
just my favorite one nice time for free
shout out the skeleton sunglasses Oh
skeleton optics his ice lenses
nice alright powerful [ __ ] psychic
invented the planetarium projector did
they realize they didn't make some
badass 1923 1923 yeah but the same
sunglasses now I think you're doing well
here six months this fat stupid fingers
so once you do once you get that then it
doesn't drop so it's not that I'm a
risk-taker is I've changed the risk so
that is low enough so that it is of on
part on par with other risks that you
take routinely I smoked a lot of pot
dude this is gonna drop I keep doing
this also the things if you pick up the
phone with one hand and it's upside down
you you hold it in places where the
center of gravity flips it but you also
have some sort of a skin in the back
which it's just it's just a sector of
Van Gogh's Starry Night oh yeah but it's
not it's there's no texture to this it's
just a slippery yeah oh it's a skin it's
definitely more texture you say feel
that that's slicker it's complicated
it's not wise there but my point is
there's no ways there but it will aid in
the friction a little scientists you
should recognize this friction is good
yes I mean isn't it one of the things
they decided to do to asteroids to
change their path spray some goo on them
and it'll literally cause more friction
in the air and cause them to deviate
slightly from their path no over a long
period of time I don't know where you
just pull that out of your ass pray in
that moment know I've read that I mean
it was some dummy vacuum of space there
is no friction so didn't there's some
[ __ ] they could put on the if it's
traveling right yes isn't there
something they could put on that would
aerodynamically change its path in the
vacuum of space there is no aerodynamics
okay so it's moving others by the time
it hits Earth's atmosphere it's too late
so it happens so it's what there was a
coating that they were planning on
putting on some aspect of would it be
the act of putting the coating that's
what you would do is you may be thinking
of there's a coating you can put on an
asteroid that differently absorbs
sunlight relative to the other side so
it caused it a spin that put there that
can that can create a net a vector
of motion is many asteroids could
protect the Earth from space rock threat
okay so there you go that's some [ __ ]
mm-hmm okay
change him out of sunlight reflected by
the space but you would not do that the
entire rock you do it to a part of the
rock potentially nudging it away from
Earth even the accumulated push provided
by many thermal photons as they radiate
from the app Wow the asteroids surface
holy [ __ ] yeah yeah see I didn't think
that through very well
and somehow you added KY jelly to this
I'm trying to flip this phone still yeah
yeah my friend Andrew Santino he carries
this [ __ ] around case free and I admire
him he's braver man than I do we I sent
you a list of topics did we hit all of
them yeah we hit all of them we didn't
hit innovation in all their cares
worries no no here's one Oh we'd never
even got into cars
yeah just line cars why they'll never be
flying cars yeah please okay since we're
two hours and 40 minutes in is that
allowed oh my gosh yeah we're flying no
but people don't have three hours to do
they oh we do it all the time really
yeah oh are you sure hundred percent
yeah this is not you sure yeah average
podcast right now lavage really yeah I'm
honored to please your average the ones
we've done we've all been like close to
three-hour okay here is that ding oh oh
it's rude okay so let me I flipped it I
turn that goddamn switch on okay so
let's go back to let's go back to why
anyone would want a flying car in the
first place because they're an [ __ ]
okay so here is stuck in traffic so here
at Edison everybody just watch let's say
there was only one road okay okay that
was the width of your car and you're
driving on this road and they're cars
behind you the fastest you could go on
that road is the speed of the slowest
car on the road right make sense yes
this is travel in one dimension
that sucks what you really want is
travel in two dimensions so you take the
road and widen it let's make two lanes
two lanes in one direction you have to
the other way as well this doesn't
matter here don't have too late so now I
can go around you your slow ass car mmm
okay but and that's fine this is a great
improvement on one-dimensional travel
now it's two dimensions okay I can shift
left or right as well as move forward or
backwards to move and the more lanes you
have the more two-dimensional that is
okay so four or five here in Los Angeles
what is it six lanes each is twelve
fricking lanes okay you are fully
exploiting the two dimensionality of
travel but you still have so many cars
that you say to yourself I want to
bypass this traffic if you went from one
dimensions to two dimensions bypassing
is just another lane but now all twelve
lanes are plugged and you want to bypass
it so you're thinking I need to travel
in another dimension I want to travel in
the third dimension if I do that I can
bypass all these cars I want a flying
car yeah okay well the point is we
already have flying cars they call
helicopters well the helicopters have
originally invented for that they called
helicopters they're noisy they have to
create a downward thrust of air equal to
its own weight if you're gonna have a
flying cart that's what it's gonna have
to do right they're noisy they're they
completely disrupt the terrain wherever
they fly so the issue is not that you
want a flying car you want to travel in
that third dimension hmm we already do
that how do we do that they call tunnels
they call bridges
when you have a huge intersection you
don't move people through one another
you build the you build one Road over
the other you build one road under the
other you are exploiting three
dimensions so that traffic can go in
perpendicular directions simultaneously
that's what the flying cars would have
given you but we do that at
intersections because it would be
impossible to move 12 lanes of traffic
through an intersection that crossed
another freeway New York City has done
this we do this the New York you're in
the streets there's too many cars
you can't move let's move in the third
dimension let's build a subway this
sounds like a guy who's trying to sell
me something I'm telling you later than
a flying car [ __ ] you could buy a
flying car the neat I want you to
appreciate moving in the third dimension
the New York City subway system moves a
billion people a year and they all go in
the third dimension beneath the ground
through tunnels tunnels that are layered
on top of one another well the New York
City subways this is amazing how I could
move that many people it's great but
it's not as good as a flying car it's
not as cool as a flying car but it's as
effective as a flying flying car flying
car just have to get in line you'd have
to get on the subway you don't have to
have a token you have to go to the
turnstile you deal with some guy who's
rubbing his body up against yours you
flying cars so you just fly around I'm
just saying it's like a boat tunnels but
for the air and bridges or flying cars
the beautiful thing about a boat is you
just go wherever you want to go now
here's the thing it's kind of you don't
have to call air traffic control okay
I'm turning left I'm gonna take you to
another dimension know someone will have
to know where the hell you're flying car
is going just the same way traffic rules
that matter in a street you want it's
not free fall you know it is with boats
and you know what happens if a car fails
Falls it's just on the on the ground it
just stops right
flying car fails you're dead right okay
so I want to add another dimension to
this conversation Oh a redline muskers
tunnels okay ready exactly exactly
so watch here's a desk in front of me
okay I it's a physical desk and I have a
lot of sheets of paper and and so I lay
them side by side i tile the desk with
all my sheets of paper then there's no
desk surface left I ran out of
two-dimensional space if I want to store
more pages on my desk what do I do I get
one of those organizers mm-hmm
I've just introduced a third dimension
so now I could have pages in another
dimension sitting above the page that
was previously occupying another place
that I couldn't have put another sheet
hmm that's three dimensions yes okay if
we were two dimensional people we would
wonder what happened to that sheet of
paper because we have no access to that
third dimension you it would just left
our universe at this point I'll be
trying to back out of the showroom and
I'd say thank you though I'm going to go
the flying car place so now watch but
look at how much you've increased your
storage by introducing another dimension
now imagine a fourth spatial dimension
we don't have access to that but we're
now filling all three dimensions and a
four dimensional creature we'll say
we'll just put it up in this direction
what would be the fourth dimension in
that regard you can't imagine it because
our brain evolved in three dimensions we
haven't we can describe it
mathematically maybe a wormhole and we
passages in LA so our storage needs
would become you can open the door put
it through this portal to the fourth
dimension right and close the door and
look on the other side of the door and
nothing would be there yeah just the way
on the surface of the desk if you live
in the surface test someone opens the
door they put the paper through the door
close the door you look around it you
say where did it go I have no idea
because you can't even see you came and
imagine that third dimension we cannot
imagine a fourth
but if the world one day gets so crowded
that even three-dimensional space has
traffic access to a fourth dimension
would greatly help that that's all I'm
saying
yeah good luck with that getting people
to step through I still what is this
Jamie some flying thing that just came
out oh look at this thing wait does see
that part seems CGI but it's actually
flying over grass why that's moving look
at this thing
what is it solar-powered I don't know
off the trailer like showing it
describing it is it have sound does it
make sound know what it looks like it
looks like a human-sized drone yes it's
exactly what it looks like okay what
about something like this what about
something like this with really powerful
magnets all outside the outer edge so it
repels against other drones to run a
maglev flying car so if you get so close
oh I see would be like a force field
landing each other Oh
so be like it'd be like a bumper car yes
but with with cushions yes yeah yeah
some sort of electromagnetic force field
that you know everyone agrees that you
don't have ones that are attracted to
each other but opposed by the way see
how big that human human size drunk
drone is have you ever heard how loud a
drone it [ __ ] laughs yeah you can't
you can't even have a conversation yeah
my neighborhood flies on around
that's what shotguns are for yeah I wish
I've never fired a gun in my life but
the first time I ever used one its to
shoot the drone that's gonna be looking
through my window at my apartment oh you
know this is [ __ ] [ __ ] on my
neighborhood he flies around all over
people's yards but I can't uncork they
already think I'm crazy no way I know if
I shoot it with a bow and arrow I'm not
sure I'll hit it by the way did that
video have sound accompanying with it
has some some a little bit there's music
and some description of it music but
there's not the actual sound of those
propellers you know this but they have
on their webpage here that it's quieter
than a car on a freeway what it's
quieter than an electric car nor at 150
feet away measured at a hundred and
fifty feet that's incredible because
it's about the same as a car as a car
well it says motors no count so that
they're counting that as an electric car
though
oh they are yeah yeah
Slean cars okay is that but cars today
are not in top where with just energy
consumption oh if they're using the same
icon to represent see they're using the
same so it's an electric car so it's the
sound of an electric car no no there's
no engine but no don't get deceived
there because that's energy consumption
see energy consumption uses the same
icon for electric cars it does for
gasoline car and then down no see it
says noise it shows highway just car it
doesn't tell you there's no way 76 DBA
is a sound because electric cars far
quieter than a regular car you all you
here's the drone of the tires no but
what happens is above a certain speed
the the aerodynamic noise is greater
than the so in a landing airplane so
here's what you do you live in LA go to
the in and out near LAX which is right
near a landing strip okay yeah and
listen to the sound of the planes as
they come as they come in for landing
most of that sound is airfoil noise not
engine noise ah yeah which is why you
can pretty much still maintain a
conversation you're old enough we
remember a plane would fly overhead in a
city and you'd have to halt your
conversation until it finished why what
happened
engines got quieter and quieter which
enabled people to build real estate
closer and closer to airports and not
have not have a sound problem that's
poor [ __ ] but they didn't happen
overnight there was slow and steady no
kidding
yeah I never Boyle boys I forgot that
you had to stop talking when I remember
it in fact Shea Stadium in New York City
near near LaGuardia Airport the the
ouncers had to stop anytime a plane flew
over it they couldn't they couldn't
announce the game that's crazy and when
the Mets were in the World Series in
1969 Mayor Lindsay redirected the
airport traffic to not fly over the
World Series games
Wow I thought that was a badass move
event of his mayor Lindsay yeah I
completely forgot how loud planes used
to be correct and now they're now there
it's a sound that's in the in quote the
noise of the street you don't even stop
and notice it you didn't even pay
attention at all you barely hear you
barely hear it and so next time you're
at a runway
and when it's landing it's much noisier
taking off because it's got a gained
altitude but coming down it's most of
that sound is glider noise and evidence
of this is is the noise of air going
over the airfoil of the the fuselage if
you do you know the moment they deploy
the the landing gear next time you're in
an airplane when they say we are cleared
for landing just listen listen to the
ambient sound of the plane then listen
to the sound after they deploy the
landing is for three times as loud it
ramps up hard part because of the sound
of the air going around something is not
aerodynamic the freaking wheels oh yes
yeah yeah yeah I just never for whatever
reason I never remembered that airplanes
used to be louder mm-hmm yeah I think
about all the time so why can't I have a
flying car
it's too you want the drone flying car
yeah yeah so you need it you wouldn't
want it
that would look ugly if two of those
colliding in the sky but what about my
magnets here what do you what do you
what night now it's got to have more
power to lift the weight of the magnet
solar bro plus you get some testosterone
infused guy who doesn't want to let you
ahead of them try to bump you then you
break the propeller and then you both
fall out of the sky sky rage sky rage oh
it's a lot of AI rage we know it'll do
it'll call the herd of testosterone
driven men okay but what if they do it
but the only way they work is through
like the same sort of Tesla system that
allows them to have you know ya know if
you have automated cars
you don't need flying cars yeah you do
because first we too many of know
there'll be fewer cars on the road but
how do you figure that
oh my gosh automated cars fewer cars yes
how so how so how so because because
what your second greatest asset your car
most people's second greatest asset
spends 90% of its time doing nothing you
drive to work in it's parked oh you come
home and it's parked 90% of his time
doing nothing okay
I come to work ten minutes after you a
half hour after you an hour after you
I'm using
car you ain't using my clutch you tell
you right now you're not using my car no
one's using your face car I forgot this
is La did you go to New York happen okay
for people with a quick steal your car
is a utility rather than a something
you're trying to get chicks with on the
street corner oh stop people try to get
chicks in New York - don't drop with the
cars there's a lot of people to do
nobody has cars but if you do you're a
baller you got one of them spots it cost
you a thousand bucks a month baby
I've seen some fancy cars when I've been
in New York there's some fancy codes but
that's not it's not it's not a hundred
percent it's not a hard percent yeah but
that's just that one stupid spot where
you could still own the car there but
you'll be delegate relegated to a lane
where you won't be able to drive as fast
as the automatically consider that if
you're in a self-driving car and it
wants to change lanes it communicates
that to other self-driving cars near it
there's self-driving cars tell you to
[ __ ] off the Joe Rogan upload I feel
like it wouldn't change anything if
there's automated cars in Los Angeles I
really do I don't think I don't think
there'd be any less traffic I just think
they're gonna make a lane that'll take
automated cars and it'll go 120 miles an
hour and watching everybody with their
wasted horsepower in there in there is
negative traffic stuck in traffic yeah I
was tweet I was in LA and I was in like
a Prius and we passed a Lamborghini
doing 40 miles an hour and that was just
seemed so embarrassing mmm - the
Lamborghini still maybe doing 30 miles
out we're doing 40 miles an hour we
passed away better no it was like why do
you have a Lamborghini because there's
some times when there's no one on the
road you got a Lamborghinis Drive late
at night the Lamborghini is the peacock
feathers as best as I can judge your
Jevon one no they're wonderful its merit
marvel of engineering and science I
should appreciate it it's good they can
go zero to 16 two and a half seconds
you're still burning gas oh you don't
like gas
not if I don't have to did you prefer
electrical if you had a car if you lived
it if for whatever reason the
planetarium decided look Neil you're the
best ever and we opened up the most
amazing spot ever it's in Los Angeles
California would love you to relocate
and bring a start on the car I'd if I
was forced to relocate and I had only
one car I'd get an electric car probably
attempt to get a Prius or a Tesla would
you go oh definitely testicle oh yeah
you wouldn't yeah I mean like you know
performance clothes Cheez Whiz Prius I'm
just saying edge that's an important car
that set a lot of other manufacturers
into motion yeah try to you know if
there's a dynamic it's a shitbox it is a
dynamic that's where nice car least one
thing happens and then you drive
something else makes that happen but
when you plug your car into the wall
you're not asking yourself I wonder
where this power comes from it could
come from any one of a dozen sources
right like hydro it could pet solar
panels a tidal energy you could come
from nukes it could come from oil or
coal come from any of them what about
clean coal have you heard about this
clean coal the president's been tweeting
about it clean coal all capital letters
like whoa
I didn't know about that I thought it
was just [ __ ] cold yeah I don't so
here's my point if you can if you can
power things with a choice of a dozen
sources of energy then those sources of
energy compete with one another for your
business mmm as the price of oil goes up
you say I'm not going to generate power
with oil we're gonna use that and I have
a wind farm and I come online I'm going
to sell you my wind energy and and I see
you're the power company you buy my wind
energy you send that power to the wall
outlet and you charge in your car don't
know and don't care where that energy
came from Wow there's a book called
turning oil into salt look it up so we
can mention drain oil and assault
correct why would you do that there was
a day when salt was a strategic
commodity yes there was no other known
way to preserve food from the autumn
harvest to
the spring set of crops so food got
salted okay yeah that's there's the book
what's the woman's name again left and
an Corrin okay so I'm now describing the
thesis of that book okay
turning oil went to salt so here's what
you do so we had salt if I took away
your assault reserves you would starve
over the winter so everybody knew where
their salt came from everybody knew how
much their salt cost do you know do you
realize that Grant General Grant destroy
the salt reserves of the Southern
Confederacy knowing that that would
force them faster to surrender because
they wouldn't have food reserves to last
through the winter I growing up Ned did
not understand the phrase you are the
salt of the earth salt gives you high
blood pressure what do you what do you
mean the salt is stop saying that sodium
does No yeah doesn't have too much right
no yeah no let's get that in a minute
let me finish the thing so they give
them something wrong with you for that
so there's whether it's chronic or not
that I agree with you there feel chronic
high blood pressure it's not just us
right right but I I can increase my
blood pressure now by not peeing and
taking an ingesting salt by not peeing
why would you not pee well because you
retain the water and it gets good pump
through this is what the salt does you
retain the liver and let me get back to
the okay so so I said salt of the earth
why is that a compliment I remember
thinking of myself but there was a day
when salt really mattered okay all right
so um so what happens the nineteenth
century
we figure out how to can foods mmm you
can have berries and put them we can
then we you seal you can make preserves
the name of the food is what it is right
it's preserved okay so now week that's
another way to protect your food to have
it last through times when you don't
have crops wait a minute refrigeration
get we have a lecture
I can refrigerate wait a minute
I can now freeze food hmm
I got a half dozen ways I can eat over
the winter and only one of them is salt
so now salt has lost its strategic value
lost his mojo lost his mojo it's still
there we still eat salted foods and as a
you know over flavor but it's a
different thing culture it's a different
thing now it's a matter of choice not a
matter of necessity a lot of great foods
came out of that you know the salted
pork and the bacon and the very tasty
foods came out of that movement okay
so right now when you buy salt do you
know where it came from
no unless you get Hawaiian salt they
should get gourmet salt from earth foods
you just buying Morton Salt you know
where it came from no do you remember
how much it cost
no it's too cheap grieve if you'd even
remember that okay if you're gonna turn
oil into salt what you're doing is
you're turning energy into salt that's
the value of a plug in the wall design a
car that can run on five different kinds
of energy then oil has to compete with
the other kinds of energy
oh I see what you're saying so have an
engine that's works on hydrogen correct
yeah yeah yeah if you sells batteries so
they have hybrids now that work on two
different things it's a start but my
point is if you do that then we no
longer fight wars for oil maybe you
don't fight for freedom
how about freedom bro freedom isn't free
free we just did three hours three hours
holy crazy how time flies by dude
astrophysics for people in a hurry
that's this is old hurry on the New York
Times bestseller seven Ray's effect 67
weeks 67 effect the unspoken alliance
between astrophysics and the military
that's not even a yessiree to war can
pre of course you can pre-order but it's
not out
they'd like it if you'd free work so
they know how to print than the thing we
got your greasy hands that's if you're
not in a hurry I'm learning some things
you're not look I'm reading uh don't buy
this book if you're not in a hurry yeah
this is this is a long-form book yes and
gentlemen you got to do some thinking
there's no pictures check that's why you
never know Neil deGrasse Tyson ladies
and gentlemen Oh start talk radio it's
it's a podcast it's also Nat Geo yeah
it's not about Sirius XM channel 121 the
insight channel I might have and cosmos
look for cosmos in the spring you know
the date isn't announced yet thank you
sir
we got a boat always love you man love
you too all right everybody
[Music]